une production du studio sf météo sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut nous inviter date si je perds je
n'entends que moi dôme piste est boosté
nouveau cette semaine le podcast est
présenté par terry un terrier nos
comptables bureaux de comptables sur
real sont super gentils 25 ans
d'expérience dans le domaine au service
des petites et moyennes entreprises de 1
à 100 employés hier dans les domaines
technologiques comme l'informatique
créateur web jeux vidéo pharmaceutiques
biotechnologiques et autres domaines
connexes
si vous allez les voir et vous
mentionnez que vous avez été référées
par le centre y de podcasts nous vous
allez avoir 50 % de rabais sur votre
première année financière puis c'est
vraiment en fait
ce que ce que je préfère est ce que j'ai
préféré de notre expérience du terrain
terriens c'est que le contact est super
humain puis rencontre ans par gentil
prennent le temps avec toi de te quitter
besoin de conseillers vraiment vraiment
super belle expérience avec eux à l'ailé
vaut quoi puis le lien vers leur site
web adoption pour ceux qui écoutent en
ce moment terrine et raidillon cpa
points comme aller voir ça son super
smash merci la gamme internet est rien
merci également à voyage aqua terra qui
est une agence de voyages moi j'ai
voyagé avec eux vous l'a peu près un an
je suis allé en jamaïque puis plus à
plus à avancement les voyages j'ai
toujours un petit peu plus de difficulté
maintenant avec l'empreinte écologique
autour des voyages c'est vraiment une
question que je me pose de plus en plus
je viens justement ce matin de les
signer une brune voitures hybrides parce
que c'est quelque chose qui me préoccupe
grandement by voyage à caudéran en fait
ils ont un compensateur co2 sur leur
site web je vous explique rapidement
c'est à carrick m'envoyer sur des
voyages aquaterra dans le fond tu écris
ton ta destination avec ton itinéraire
de vol et 7 10 c'est quoi ton impact co2
et ça te propose ensuite d'acheter
l'équivalent en arbre pour pour
rembourser en fait ton empreinte
écologique donc par exemple je le
faisais avec un voyage possible
wyplay samedi
en tout 40 dollars de plus de ton voyage
puis dans le fond vous êtes projet de
voyager avec voyage côté rock pour avoir
accès à ce compensateur de co2 c'est
super cool sinon ils y ont des pommiers
où est-ce qu'ils vont être toute leur
équipe cueillir des pommes à chaque
année pour donner au petit déjeuner il
plante un arbre à chaque réservation la
meilleure agence de l'année
voté par l'industrie dont care canada 5
min transat qui ont voté pour voyager
comptera c'est vraiment des stades du
voyage donc allé voir sur en fait aller
sur leur site le site qui va être dans
la déception on les remercie beaucoup de
faire affaire avec le sang fait de
podcasts puis on les remercie également
pour leurs initiatives environnementales
on sait que c'est un enjeu extrêmement
important de nos jours
sinon c'est m cette semaine de claudia
bouvette une
comédienne mais surtout chanteuse
musicienne dans l'âme en fait c'est sa
première passion goulon connu avec
justement ce sésame action à lesquin 0
avec la musique qu'il est tout jeune
c'est son rêve c'est ce qu'on veut faire
et maintenant son rêve devient réalité
avec son premier ep paru déjà quelques
mois donc on a fait la rétrospective un
peu de son parcours de la comédie
musicale avait 12 ans à mixmania 2 a
justement une période d'écriture que pas
partir en partie fruits à son premier ep
tout seul on est tombé encore une fois
dans le brassage d'émotion et de d'idées
comme comme on le fait si bien ces
temps-ci on est en période de
questionnement exactement puis bah si
c'est super finesse pardo laisse pas à
lui mais c'est encore une fois un très
beau podcast s
sinon dans un autre ordre d'idée sur le
sans fil du vip donc disponible
seulement pour nos membres pétrole on a
reçu cédric martel way qui est un
musicien avec que tu connais depuis un
petit bout qui nous a parlé de ses
problèmes de dépendance aux drogues de
sa réhabilitation de sa nouvelle vie
maintenant qui va en tournée avec vécu
ben ouais avec hubert surtout donc c'est
vraiment un super conversation si vous
voulez aller écouter se diriger vers la
page piquionne abonnez vous en plus ça
nous supportent tout le monde est
content sinon vous n'écoutez pas entrer
en ce moment sur une plate forme là bas
fond de votre choix
laissez un commentaire laissé au retail
essais en top laisser tout ce qui peut
nous aider vous savez comment
l'algorithme fonctionne en fait non
personne sait comment acquérir mais tout
ce qu'on peut faire c'est cessé de
partager la bonne nouvelle le plus
possible enfin le groupe continue à
faire grossir le sang fait pas de
castres on vous aime toutes la gagne on
est content que vous soyez là merci à
nos sponsors terrain terriens voyage à
côté ras puis sans plus attendre bon
podcast bon écoute
[Musique]
oh oui et c'est fait c'est parti on a
commencé très jeune en trois matches ils
ont jeté les actrices de course toute la
journée puis là c'est bon d'être là
c'était pour le temps de jeu black adam
a été un succès son pote car je flippe
agit pas agi pas un candidat vraiment
aimé ce n'est pas ça qui te diriger des
feedbacks mais j'ai oublié preuves sur
mac j'ai eu des quelques personnes qui
m'ont mentionné qu'il avait coûté 4 us
and roll mais voir un peu pété mais
ouais c'est cool mais je me sentis
vraiment décousu du début à la même
quand j'étais quand je n'avais pas fait
son effet je me sentais oserais-je
appréhender je fais chier je me sentais
comme paul n'était pas prête d'être
meilleur yara d'amour il tournait puis
j'en ai prions et juste avant de
retourner chez nous parce que ses
parents une grosse journée de podcasts
comme le j'avais besoin de justes chili
de prix avant de retourner chez vous
ouais c'est ça rentre chez nous comme ge
plus déconnectés berrada expérienc holtz
et puis c'est ce que j'ai fait depuis
finalement c'est un boss qui doit
vraiment longtemps crosland c'est
vraiment la chose s'est péniblement
c'est trop c'est quand même long c'est
quand même long pis c'est assez intense
le genre je me verrais pas agir sous
l'effet de ce juge plutôt que c'est trop
dangereux toute la ligne est mince entre
vive le meilleur moment de ta vie une
overdose juste est dans le pire vague de
lui même témoin si des fois il suffit
d'un regard mal placé peut même pas toi
qui me donne un lobby
mais ça va repartir rapidement en vrille
ouais ça que c'est un impôt fait route
oui je sais c'est pour des podcasts ils
vont être vues par dizaines de milliers
personnes jusqu'à présent je suis parti
d'ici
puis j'ai été prêté pendant trop
longtemps ils étaient dix ans reçoivent
j'aime qu'on me ramène quelques mois et
des mois sans lendemain tout allait bien
la masse et c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose qui trop long -selon pis mettons
qui cite pas de stimuli tu tombe
rapidement complètement dans le vide
mais comme tu mets ton une capote
quelque chose pas quelqu'un à qui parler
de ses matons sur un podcast même si des
fois c'est peut-être décousu relatifs au
moins dans une conversation qui te
ramène tout le temps mais quand rien qui
te ramène des fois tu par le kenyan su
rentrer chez nous tu sais plus je me
suis mieux la jouer à la playstation
malouin de l'homme et tranchant qui
adorent mais je souhaite jouer à
playstation puis des fois je perdais
comme jouer à nba
des fois je manque une période au
complet que je me réveille ses calmes
qui j'ai joué
et comme je pense que je me dis qu'il
est dans le coin de scène alors mais
j'en jouais mais comme en mode je suis
pas un mode automatique c est quand même
8 mai mais mes pilotes renseignements un
peu boiteuse à un segway un peu boiteux
verbe artamuse et pourtant c'est la
musique que tu fais maintenant que moi
je trie badauds et puis ce genre de
musique que j'écoute répéter y ait ce
genre est organisée pour base proposés
mais jardin vibe mais c'est pour moi
c'est le dit yes comme si moi je loge il
a de la personne qui fume beaucoup au
tac aux bottes pas de compléments
peuvent vraiment pas mon truc mais
mettons quelqu'un qui me dit que c'est
de la musique pour se péter juste pour
moi simple compliments passe a dit que
c'est super planète
c'est la musique que je serai en faisant
l'amour jeu comme il ya ce style of
making music ou gens pour faire de l'eau
chelsea comme les trois autres images
comme coluche passivité en fait c'était
pas nécessairement je veux faire de la
musique pour que j'ai ce genre de
commentaire là c'est plus le genre de
musique qui moi me fait le point j'aime
ça être la musique que j'aime le plus
c'est quand je suis en voiture puis que
je tombe dans une espèce de transe de
dépenser ou même pas dépenser juste de
contempler la route les armes que la
musique me fait vivre un moment c'est ce
qui me fait triper dans la musique fait
que ça quand j'ai ce genre de compliment
leur bain je suis content c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que la musique c'est
tellement c'est tellement une question
de méthode qui est pas capté pas quand
le cerveau en mode analytique la musique
mais jusque quand tu te laisses porter
moi j'avais j'écoutais dirait bélanger
chez nous depuis tout petit j'ai emmené
gelé comme le découvreur qu'ange jeu des
bus 21 ans maintenant le titre
c'est ce que j'écoute est pratiquement
que du dal et bélanger
l'album lui j'imagine belgique ans j'ai
redécouvert rêver mieux l'album rêver
mieux
je sortais de chez nous je prenais mon
vélo puis j'écoutais l'album en
zigzaguant d'un rhume et comme
intouchable et mortelle dresser tout
leur laisser planer s'apprend genre de
musique linge plat tu fais juste
regarder les étoiles plutôt direct on
dirait qu'il est à côté de toi qu'un
qu'écrivait c'est un type des brahmanes
ce genre de vrais bleus c'est vrai que
la musique tu te portes de cette façon
là celle écoute vraiment ça peut
t'amener vraiment des ondes ça va
chercher quelque chose qui est pas une
chose qu'on recherchait la musique c'est
qu'ici rouge et j'ai su à un moment
donné je me suis pas le meilleur
pourcentage la société qui ressentent
absolument rien en écoutant la musique
c'est quelque chose de gpj je peux c'est
génétique mais c'est juste c'est un fait
ça
rien qui se produit je pense que
j'aurais envie de ne plus vivre sans
aucune émotion à l'hectare fanta j'ai
aussi des gens qui sont incapables de
faire de la musique mais trop tenir au
but les gens sont quand même bien chanté
une note juste donc sont capables
d'apprécier la musique sur hbo c'est le
genre de personne mais je pense que
c'est maintenant mon père un salut papa
c'est le la personne qui chante les
moins bien mais sans mener c'en est
ridicule
il ya comme pote ya pas de ringuette
dont il peut chanter même vraiment très
fort oui paul ont voté mais y'a pas il
n'y a pas de degré fa qui chante char du
queens qui les y est super fier mais
comme il faut ce qu'un petit peu un
petit maginez puisque meringue un
running gag chez nous mais pourtant
c'est lui qui m'a transmis la passion de
la musique
c'est un les seniors le puits lui c'est
comme il ya des albums à n'en plus finir
à la maison puis moi j'achète des albums
- dans la dernière année mais j'ai
toujours acheté des albums physiques
j'ai une bobine dans mon auto et puis
moi j'ai pas de fil auxiliaires
acceptant des albums c'est vrai que j'ai
transmis sa fac je vous confirme que ce
peut être un chien
oui la passion c'est autre chose ma
passion pour la musique c'est mon parent
il s'était fait dire de faire semblant
de chanter qu'inquiéter dans son cours
de code
la prof y avait dit que plus aux
toitures ouvrir la bouche surfer comme
c'est touchant à sa tu veux pas chanter
pourquoi ben parce qu'ils étaient trop
faux comme les spectacles emmenait
pleurer ce stade je sais pas quoi fait
que c'est ce qu'a fait puis là il ya
toujours gardé sa passion pour la
musique c'est jusqu'à mais celui-ci
cohabiter avec judas lady conducteur
allait chanter dans la classe et puis
c'est grâce à lui que j'ai découvert ce
combo 6% à 30 mg ou du châtelet où ça
peut être faux assume mais bon sait pas
s'il faut chanter passe mal on ne sait
pas s'il faut population ouais
mais la peur est la passion c'est une
affaire qui le talent sa nounou depuis
les deux sons peuvent être sont pas
nécessairement les deux pays distincts
mais c'est quoi c'est quoi tu écoutais
mettons parce que faisons un peu la
rétrospective de commandes en est avec
un mental est arrivé avec la version de
toi
aujourd'hui la musique que tu fais
maintenant on s'entend que te pas sorti
grand chose à vendre pas on ne
connaissait mais pas tant que ça pour ta
musique fait quelqu'un qui sait quoi qui
t'a amené entre ce processus là dessus
quand je veux sortir quelque chose ça va
être ce qui est ultra unique dans le
paysage musical au québec comme ça ça se
fait porter qu'un quant aux sorties
kool-aid j'ai écouté j'ai fait
complètement nouveautés comme j'ai
jamais entendu ce ici ça s'est jamais
fait ici puis qu'est-ce qui t'a amené
comme sur ce chemin là parce qu'on
s'entend tu étais jeune 4 été mis dans
l'oeil du public
j'ai fait mixmania j'avais 15 à 20 15 16
ans puis avancez en fait mon premier
contrat ville qui est comme un peu tout
chambouler ça a été premièrement j'ai
décroché un rôle dans une comédie
musicale à québec s'appelle annie c'est
un gros con tre à mon âge c'était 15
représentations dans le temps des fêtes
pendant un mois de temps c'était six
mois de répète chaque mois au secondaire
j'ai manqué mon après midi mon vendredi
après-midi d'école pour monte à québec
faire des répètes toute la fin de
semaine dans sim autant c'est comme ça
mes parents qui ont été l'oeuvre qui
m'ont comme par ses poteaux contre
gilles mais certainement poches des gens
saoudite et j'étais un bébé et ça me
surprendrait que je t'ai pas vu comment
c'est que j'avais pas vu cette pièce
c'était parce que ma prochaine québec
qui genre mais tombée par un cd de mai
2007 2009 2010 salle dina-bélanger une
école de filles
[Musique]
mais je connais très bien animé je sais
c'est quoi il leur fait l'ena rose way
we gendarmes français
ce n'est pas l'heure je crois ce que je
lis juste à pièce le et ça c'est grave
aussi la photo que j'ai pris avec toi la
fin acteurs du livre - fax et ça a été
comme un élément déclencheur pour moi
qui me comme un peu confirmé que j'avais
envie de faire ça dans la vie mais mais
c'est quand même quelque chose de vrai
que je suis né avec où je sais pas si
c'est dans mon sang
mais moi tout jeune j'en étais gosse en
jeu j'ai regardé des vidéos de moi des
vhs et paul ont de moi de mon frère
quand tu es petit et je te jure sans
négoce ans et je sais que je savais
faire des spectacles puis moi je fais je
faisais juste sait-on les parties de
famille de monter une pièce de théâtre
avec ton frère
mon frère y est influence aujourd'hui
lui tripes et soeurs quand l'argent
quand on était petit et ailleurs sur une
caisse enregistreuse je ne devrais le
magazine people
j'étais fasciné aujourd'hui et
financiers mais c'est le meilleur qui
sait pas quand est ce que je suis mais
d'exemple princesse je faisais des paies
stack qui mon frère mais mon grand père
il ya eu la bonne la bonne idée d'y
montrer que ça valait quelque chose des
spectacles cefac faut qu'ils mettent des
coussins avant de rentrer dans le salon
faute de charge le monde faut respecter
ça on savait bien se faire réprimander
oui l'homme la famille au complet c'est
pas vrai suivi pias avec des 25 cents et
on capote et puis enfin que ça a
commencé par contre l'argent à 81,62 car
je croyais plus grosse bombe à mes yeux
mais
que ça fait longtemps que ça fait partie
de ma vie c'est juste de vouloir faire
respecter
puis absolue à nice il ya eu toute la
saga sont en spectacle pendant mon
secondaire comme namur et ses spectacles
ouais je vais en fait il y en a je pense
j'ai participé trois années de suite la
première star qu'on a un pied en fait
c'est la première fois que j'ai
performer devant public puis d'ailleurs
ça a été un élément vraiment déclencheur
parce que moi je chantais tout le temps
je chantais tout le temps mais j'étais
pas bien de chanter devant le monde je
sais pas pour que j'avais comme la peur
de l'inconnu
c'est comme un peu une gens de phobie de
1,1 en moi je peux même pas m'imaginer
le faire
amman et maman m'a juste dit berlocq
l'odeur va falloir que tu que tu
laissais au moins juste pour voir
sinon je te paye des cours de chant mais
ça ça va rien s'est il se doit le savon
jargonne sa tombe
jf frey participent à ce qu'on
inspecteurs qui dans mon audition devant
trois des preuves de mon école j eus
l'espèce des défauts qui m'aiment pas
les sésames drague de pas trop savoir
juste l'espèce de c'est le spot belle et
15 secondes avant de rentrer je vais
mourir
je voulais mourir vraiment je me suis
mise à chanter proposé les trois juges
ont applaudi jeux sortis sur un rail de
reich pot mort je me sens accompli j'ai
besoin d'avoir fait quelque chose de
plaisant ça comité le début de l'amour
de la musique
je pense que c'était avant annie
d'ailleurs mai puis après ça c'est super
forme et une toune s'appelait mon ami
pierrot c'est une chanson qui a été
écrit par un auteur compositeur de grand
baie
qui
je me serais rendu aux provinciaux
régionaux je pense
coup de coeur avec cette chanson love
active et un sentiment d'accomplissement
et à qui je m'en moque page j'aime ce
jeu je me découvre là dedans ça l'année
d'après j'ai fait dieu existe avec la
cgil moi ce que ces fous pareils
d'avancé tout citoyen un déclic de faire
comme ça c'est le sport parce que je
pense pas que je pense pas cessé c'est
vraiment une bonne chance mais c'est
quelque chose de tellement c'est notre
maître gratifiant mois à brûle pourpoint
comme ça je ne sais pas j'aime bien
passer un moment j'ai fait des cas déjà
avoir un moment où est ce que toi
musique s'était jamais fait arriver
quant à mener dès que tu es dans un des
projets que tu as fait de faire comme
acquis dans ce souci c'est le truc moi
la plus proche qui se rapproche je suis
assez c'est en écriture quand j'écrivais
pour les éditions pas un quand
j'écrivais des contes pour enfants dit
que j'avais vraiment là comme la liberté
complète de décrire ce que je voulais
être des histoires qu'il faut être
complètement fucked up tipi puis d'avoir
les enfants qui reconnaissait les
personnages mettant résultats rappelle
m'a dit ok non c'est cool c'est sûrement
ce si c'est ça me fait du bien mais si
c'est tellement une chance de découvrir
ce jour que plein monde qui passent leur
vie sans avoir de moments comme ceux
suisse s'est piqué le titan qui pense la
vie c'est surtout parce que je pense que
la vie c'est comme de juste titre phare
le chemin qu'on te donner parce que tu
as peut-être jamais essayé de faire
quelque chose dans lequel devrait
vraiment rapidement je me demande si le
fait de devoir trouver un peu ma voix
jeunes 1 incidence
e justement tout ce que tu dis c'est à
dire avoir la certitude de ce que je
veux faire dans la vie j'en ai passé
c'est sûr que j'ai l'impression que les
plus peut-être que son exposition qui
est fausse mais je pense à autre voile
je suis passé plus de vieillir plus tu
t'en cre dans un quotidien plus tendres
dans les habitudes de la vie puis deux
dépouilles dans tes première fois un
rotor mais que c'est plus dur à aller
chercher très bonnes mentions par l'ats
jean martin aussant
voici qui fait de la politique et de
l'économie sur la politique que fait de
la politique en fait et lui nous disait
c'est en toute transparence de sister
force européenne east ah ouais parce que
probablement découvert ce spot le plus
tard dans sa vie parce qu'il avait
découvert mais que le fameux chemin dans
le parti ouais ouais c'est aussi j'ai
l'impression que moi j'ai eu une chance
immense d'avoir des parents qui m'ont
réellement supportés comme quasiment
trop mais pas trop mais le sens où et
ils m'ont donné accès à tout moment
donné la chance d'essayer tout se fait
que ça m'a probablement donner une
opportunité de faire le tri pis des
essais ce juste d'essayer
j'imagine que des enfants qui ont
conscience qu'ils ont pas cette chance
sur deux de ses seins d'essayer des
trucs ici je n'ai pas quitté un cours de
piano cours des centres de secours de ce
ca fait que justement c'est au
championnat fermé moustrou si mes
parents m'avaient pas inscrit un plus à
ma demande et des cours de piano quand
j'avais 7 ans
moi par contre mes parents ils m'ont
inscrit à tous mais n'était pas très
rigide
ils ont été vraiment ils ont été des
facettes importantes de l'éducation d'un
enfant j'ai l'impression mais on était
aussi très libertin vie nous ont laissé
beaucoup de liberté à prendre nos
propres décisions ce que je trouve
vraiment chouette
mais je me souviens ce ne serait moi
j'ai fait du violon jeune je pratiquais
peut-être 20 minutes dans ma semaine
puis mes parents mettaient pas de
pression avec ce team me laissait juste
vivre ma vie c'est vous qui payez si
yamaha qui peut-être juste un peu de
dignité à ce niveau la vie j'arrivais
dans mes cours de violon qui mon prof de
violence il était nommé france à l'âge
de 10 ans mme hervieux jeunesse la
roumanie 1-1 romain mary chain et
c'était une sommité un violon qui
j'étais son élève préférée puimoisson
s'adoraient et pourtant je pratique
beaucoup quand je reviens dans mon cours
ont pensé maintenant 45 minutes de leur
agent zéro de ce colloque qui on avait
un grand loto
moi j'étais contente parce que je pense
qu'il va bien bien charles huot obèses
plus est par le sable on a ça plaît même
à s'appeler quoi déjà ça s'appelait
marie ohana qui m'avait donné le truc
pense à la marijuana ainsi quand la
bâtisse mal à ces bombes avaient cessé
les élèves c'est qui qui ont besoin de
soins c'est vraiment quand même
thérapie triple c'est comme ça quand des
paroles comme une thérapie dans ce
fauteuil à toute fin pratique une
thérapie parce que c'est injuste aux
oreilles que tu écoutes oui je pense une
pop et oreilles mais tu savais par
rapport au mois dernier dont jaar site
chine mais je pense qu'ils avaient été
presque et iggy pop dance est connue
pendant quatre ans je suivais des cours
devant michael dont là des fois je
n'arrivais plus modérément offrande de
chacun cette semaine je voulais
travailler les gammes et double coup
mais je rêve là on va checker gavin
harrison beau regarder des vidéos genre
de drames en défaut c'est sa faute face
et moi j'ai donné des cours des guides
beaucoup des fois ci c'est en fait c'est
vraiment plus de psychologie que de la
musique l'été parce que tu justement des
tchèques et les vidéos de rome c'est
peut-être ce qui va donner le coup de
presse qui bien plus que de jardy
l'autre aux pratiques internationales
concernant fatigue des fautes et la
proche coule déjà pcb motivant qui est
moins la pression brise toutes les canal
la créativité même thème quand je
m'assois puis j'essaie d'écrire quelque
chose
youri seul c'est à coup sûr il va varier
après c'est un moment donné c'est
niaiseux joue être je me perds un peu
sur youtube je vais tomber sur une vidéo
qui vient vraiment inspiré d'un artiste
que j'aime qui comme tu fonctionnes
pique une vision qui en parle
il a juste vraiment inspiré tout d'un
coup pige or le goût de m'asseoir à mon
piano pic juste jamais mais ce que j'ai
l'impression aussi dans la création de
ton épée que c'était pas mis de pression
depuis longtemps séparé joue vite et
j'écoute et je te demande pas très
attaqué la moto fait pis si ça a pris un
an dans le fond le tri le processus le
kivu a fait trente chansons de pycon ton
tour est là tant pis si c'est essayer
d'avoir le temps puis le
de se donner le temps passe et le luxe
le genre de la chronique juste pleine
zone valait vraiment chanceux l'équipe
meilleur pied gauche et puis on va
regarder quoi puis justement ça paraît
quand t'écoutes ce qui est une recherche
d'une maturité c'est justement moi j'ai
été vraiment comme j'ai gagné deux
minutes les 40 ans du ton épée pour un
gecko m ok j'en sais pas c'est pas à
rueil je le sais si comme beaucoup mais
vraiment gentil tu vois je te manquer au
niveau de son d'écouter quelque chose
des jeans là-dedans mais ça a été pour
moi de replonger dans la musique après
presque cinq ans j'avais pas je me
donnais pas le choix de faire quelque
chose qui n'était pas à la hauteur de
mes propres à toi ça a été oui un an de
d'écriture pistes de recherche musicale
avis de recherche de son adresse a été
aussi un build up d'une vie c'est un
espèce de foi d'une appréhension de jeu
c'est ça que je veux moi ce que je veux
dans la vie c'est d'abord un bijou un
petit quelque chose qui m'appartient
un projet qui mois en dans son entièreté
par contre sans compromis que j'ai envie
de performer dans tout les coins de la
planète si ça adonne ou si ça adonne pau
nay coins du québec ccss parfait mélange
ans où j'ai ce processus le été comme ça
m'a vraiment permis de me comprendre à
travers la ce que je voulais mais aussi
ça a été libérateur de permettre
d'essayer d'essayer puisses tu le dis
tantôt seuil c'est vraiment un luxe de
cette donnée ce temps lyon ça arrive
plus et on est comme des baies les épis
on a des budgets me fais moi qui connais
ce qu'on a décidé c'est qu'on se
rencontre et ça tellement été
fusionnelle musicalement un conseiller
donnez leur à l'autre du temps un pion
shayler jouanard mondanités avait une
semaine et en californie à la maison
socan soca puis
on a écrit pendant une semaine sans
arrêt après ça y est revenu on faisait
que des sessions qu'on est passé par
toutes les étapes
ce qui fait qu'à la fin on a réduit les
trente chansons à à 8 puis on lisait
peaufiné jusqu'à ce que moi je fasse que
moi je pense qu on le sait vous devez la
classe 6e mais en fait c'est a eu la
sagesse la bonne décision de pas trop
pressé mais je pense que ce cas une
qualité que j'ai merdé fois en même
temps tu demanderas en afrique qui me
connaît mes proches je j'ai pas de
misère à être patient dans la vie puis
je suis de celles chez ces personnes qui
pensent que rien n'arrive pour rien fac
j'ai peu disert a juste laissé plané
puis à vivre les choses même si ça va
pas aussi vite que ce que je voudrais
qu'ils -selon le 50 m dans ma petite vie
à attendre ce soir à mixmania après ce
jeu me s'auto produite
un album qui jamais sorti puis s'était
pas mauvais mais j'avais 17 18 ans
j'avais comme lui
l'espèce d'urgence de vouloir être une
artiste accomplie d'écrire mes propres
affaires dette c'est d'être intègre pis
d'être authentique mais j'avais jamais
rien fait
donc là que j'apprenais subito à écrire
j'avais le syndrome de la page blanche
blanche parce que j'avais jamais fait ce
jeu mettait de la pression parce que je
voulais y arriver
et finalement j'ai réussi à aborder des
chansons qui étaient comme parsemé de
moi mais c'était grosso modo le
producteur avec qui je travaille et qui
mettait sa sauce a subit finalement puis
le jeter indépendante fait moi qui la
personne n'a plus comme distraite et
bohème et lunatique je n'avais pas la
capacité d'aller cogner le monde
s'affaire le
j'avais pas cette fougue là où j'en suis
côté créatif je sais ce que je veux
c'est le même temps je sais c'est que je
fais me défunt et puis après ça de le
mettre en marche et j'ai besoin de
l'équipe kg pis c'est ce qui fait que
j'arrive à être complète
moi j'ai besoin de ça il y en a d'autres
qui sont vraiment bons à son plus bel
nice est malade mais moi je sais que
j'ai posté fac ce premier album le
aujourd'hui je regarde en arrière puis
comme dit merci c'est pas sorti parce
que ça ça me permise de juste partir
mais vu les coups dessus aujourd'hui
différent mais c'est drôle j'ai les
épaules on s'en rappellera bien des
souvenirs de cette de ce moment là de ma
vie c'est pas mauvais ce qui est
vraiment des bonnes idées mais s'était
exécuté d'une manière qui parce que
j'aurais voulu finalement c'est dur mais
je pense vraiment que des bonnes idées
peut-être que je retourne et puis j'ai
un joueur mais rock un peu d'entre eux -
wef accueil où nous sommes et ça c'est
vraiment drôle comme des fois j'avais
envie de le faire écouter à des gens que
j'aime juste pour qu'on convient peu de
cette étape de ma vie mais moins qu est
qu est ce que la majeure partie ton
temps tu sais danser ça gueule ça a été
mais je suis devenu comme comédienne
sans crier gare j'avais pas prévu du
tout qui sait être être comédienne c'est
d'abord une horaire qui en fait de ne
pas avoir d'horaires enfin que j'ai
décroché un premier rôle dans 30 vies
après uspto texto animation jeunesse de
télé-québec bien ce que j'ai mis bien
travers tous aux yeux quelques petits
contrôles qui m'occupait
mais assez pour avoir de la misère à
donner de la tête
pleinement un projet un projet en
musique fait que je pisse et peut-être
aussi du leasing ou juste justement donc
pas se mettre la pression aux pièces
utiles aux professionnels et un peu de
moins en moins klose c'est moins
péjoratif que progrès sns tw alors j'ai
pas nous allons aller au parc à côté de
chez nous on est les jeux les affaires à
faire mais juste un peu trop et depuis
lors ce qui est un peu de ça mais
j'avais je sais pas j'avais un feeling
qu'il fallait que j'attends d'avoir un
moment une carte blanche de comminges en
de six mois à donner de la tête qu'à se
racheter je sais je le filet pas fake
c'est pour ça que j'ai comme attendu
puis je sais pas où je viens cailloux
poirier aujourd'hui ballon tu as un
projet qui me représente puis qui me
rend fier pour de vrai que ça n'a pas de
prix
pis ces rencontres là que j'ai fait avec
colin mais quand même a été présenté par
la gamme de chez korn ascione qui
aujourd'hui somme c'est mon les bonnes
pièces et des jeunes qui ont de la faute
puissance des cds visionnaire qui sont
qui ont leur style propre à eux mais qui
résonne aussi avec qui je suis qui sont
vraiment très respectueux de de
l'artiste que j'ai envie d'être puis
qu'il faut sont juste pour me supporter
puis faire arriver tu fais tout ça
d'après moi c'est parce que toulouse
mais 15 mai à travailler ça va
travailler fort ah oui moi c'est c'est
tout ou rien un sens où quand je donne
un objectif et je mens je vais en
travaillant tu sais juste que des fois
j'ai besoin d'un peu de structures
puissent justement avec connu dans la
dernière année lui qui est à l'opposé de
moi sans doute c'est un petit génie le
yo yo 25 20 25 un violeur d'en avoir 57
mais qui m'aiment pas physiquement
ce faire violer non mais
mais d'ici un an men il est dans sa
dernière vis à ce pôle est tellement
relax qui est vraiment l'énergie d'un
vieil très posé et peu impressionné de
rien mais candidats à la fois très très
mais tellement laisser de liberté m'a
permis de me découvrir dans tout ça
parce que après cinq ans plus tard mon
steak comme je recommence à zéro le 15
mars d'une toile blanche
exactement il m'a donné la chance de
juste y aller à fond puis de peut être
pas avoir peur de ces des trucs de de
massue mais dans ce que je ressens pie x
qui grâce à lui je donnerai un verbal
jeu c'est vraiment ce que je veux quand
j'entends des trucs pige capable de le
verbaliser puis lui maintenant puisqu'il
comprendra plus mon extension parce que
ce qu'on est vraiment petit je lui
connais mes histoires personnelles de
fond en comble puis tu es des détails
que je compterai paumé que je les compte
parce que je sais que ça peut être ça
peut être bénéfique d avoir juste des
petits dans des petits hedge dans des
chansons au niveau de pas des paroles
c'est ça qui ne connaît vraiment bien
mais ça me fait que maintenant on sait
on des fois je j'arrive pour dire
quelque chose puis si je viens de le
faire ouais vraiment hier à damier
reçues sur le podcast carlos munoz les
gars de bosses de la wec yj oui oui
celui d'orly maj voici ce à pied
puisqu'ils faisaient c'était toutes les
sous si vous pensez qu'ils un artiste
qui est seul
vous vous trompez parce que c'est
l'équipe autour de ces gens là y'a
personne qui est capable de tout faire
tout seul une personne qui a l'idée qui
est capable de tout mettre en place
pierre gensse ont dérogé 6,15
manager ouais je connais un petit peu
font tout pour la belle et tendre à
gauche le qui composent graal easytone
mature il fait des clips et visuels
il ya personne qui leur donne des kew
pour les mettons pas tout ce qu'il ya
pas de solution c'est une exception tout
ce qu'ils ont je pense et un bouquet de
leur tournée internationale
et c'est fou quand même métier si comme
le gosse aujourd'hui puisque génie
[ __ ] qui travaille 20 heures sur 24
sauf que mais oui je suis d'accord avec
toi qui es c6 et ben vous les mettez
c'est le monde avec 80 au dessus je dois
je sais pas parce qu'il est une vision
artistique c'est pas parce que la
capacité écrire les paroles soit parce
que picard de chanter parce que tu as
une vision tout ce que tu es capable de
produire la musique comme un petit 2 je
voudrais ya tout plein de technicalités
le titre je parlais tantôt tu as much
c'est la marge c'est tout voir le
dernier mot au final sur l'amour je le
trouve que le poteau qui va gérer le
sous contractants qui avec qui tu vas
faire venir le principe auto qui va
faire ça allait à mesa l'imprimerie ses
poteaux qui va faire le shipping de sa
faute et c'est tout et tout des affaires
qui s'éloigne tellement du côté
artistique que c'est impossible pour un
artiste à ses puits dans mon co
particulièrement si essentiel d'avoir
des gens qui font ça pour moi parce que
si ça existait pas la gérance puis une
équipe qui je sais pas je serai ou
cyclables c'est tout à fait une question
légitime si tu veux te concentrer sur
des trucs mais faut que tu ailles du
monde qui se situe cependant les
expertises un nombre limité mais tant
d'heures dans la gestion des affaires
thales - pour créer exactement oui c'est
ça peut devenir castrés un certain
niveau d'abord des gens qui te jarpa
dents
on colle mais en même temps ça donne une
grande liberté à ne pas avoir à se
soucier avec des affaires qui qui est
pour moi sont ingérables simon je vous
parle je peux vous parler de mon frère
sur le podcast ou avant mon frère ahmed
mais c'est une bénédiction
on est super proche de la dore mon
enfant mais c'est lui qui gère mon
compte qui les gèrent toutes mes
affaires si comme l'oeil et s'est rendu
mon coloc depuis cette année fac s'est
rendu lui maintenant qui fait mon
transfert au proprio j'ai rien à faire
puis ça fait tellement du bien
les finances en plus c'est mon frère
quand il ya un attachement géorgie fait
tellement confiance et puis c'est le
meilleur qui est en train de faire son
om c est faux tout y est vraiment bright
qui il est vraiment au texas pour moi
c'est essentiel de la mort si je l'avais
pas je serai doublement perdre a pu tuer
quelqu'un qui est quelqu'un qui est qui
qui n'est que développé une expertise
dans quelque chose se savait prendre une
offre quelque chose que toi vas t'en
prendre vraiment complexe rapidement que
je trouve que c'est important d'avoir
trouvé sur wii puis jeu mais je pense
que je suis choyé d'avoir choisi d'avoir
choisi une équipe qui qui qui un peu à
l'image de ce que j'ai envie d'être bien
qui j'ai confiance c'était important
d'être bien encadré
puis malheureusement dans ce milieu
c'est pas toujours le copi suffit
d'avoir une trop grosse équipe pour un
peu passé dans le beurre c'est parce que
je viens en ce moment fait que pour moi
c'est un gros bonus mais c'est tout ce
qui touche à notre jeu pour faire la
grosse artillerie et et charlotte mais
on est chanceux on est les deux seuls
qui s'étaient tous les deux seuls
faculté parce que c'est une jeune une
jeune boîte de
caen et lyon ont aidé à produire des
artistes mais sont nés les deux seuls
signé - fax à saran le contact vraiment
direct ces maladies en bleu c'est toute
la presle qui a été fait avec charlotte
les comptes à moi aussi puis moi charlot
jah jah trouve malade et j'ai les coups
de pied c'est un artiste qui ait jamais
beaucoup quand même temps je suis aussi
chaud seul phone qu'on soit deux
artistes différentes dans les deux
styles propres à chacune ses fans aussi
parce que pas de compétition mais j'ai
moi je ressens pas du tout les deux
on est on prend soin les qui prend soin
chacune de nous faxer s'écoule au site
c'est vraiment surtout surtout de faire
confiance à un projet qui c'est loin
tellement de de ce conte et de ce qu'on
entend ici c'est le ski mais ton il ya
une lionne une recette le au québec pour
jouer à radio pour pour tourner pour
faire ses affaires le puits de faire
confiance à un brunch le tien puis
charlotte sur une chose qui s'éloigne
tellement de ce chantier le tlm envie de
dire
georges bach sortie du bac ce billet ou
non de au nom du risque
ouais risque là derrière tout cela si ça
se peut que ça se peut que tu - radio
mais oui oui qu'en plus c'est fait que
moi c'est un projet anglo ce mois-ci
grandement mais mes chances de jouer à
la radio mais mais pour moi de le suivre
mon instinct au niveau de ce que j'avais
envie de créer
il y avait il n'y avait pas de compromis
à faire comme ça c'est plutôt j'avais
envie d'aller leur pied j'ai pas dis pas
non plus le goût de faire de la musique
radio faune et j'ai pas envie de faire
un single qui voit clairement passer à
la radio mais qui pour moi c'est un
petit peu bonbon fait que la lan et de
recherche musicale c log ça a été ça eu
son effet c'est justement d'aider de
vouloir de moi je voulais vraiment
développer un son jeu développé un sens
c'était ça mon but puis c'est même quand
on jasait plus tôt et quand charlie de
te fait des études en jazz puis moi je
trouve ça vraiment sic parce que
j'aurais dû pas que j'aurais dû
mais j'avais j'avais cette option le
temps d'étudier en musique puis je l'aï
pas fait parce que j'avais aussi un
atout de ce fils inc âgées comme je le
fais au pot j'ai peur de me faire mettre
dans une boîte puis de finir par
entendre ce que je dois entendre
j'ai envie d'avoir rien qui m'influence
ne serait-ce que de la musique que
j'écoute puis d'essayer de construire
quelque chose à partir de semences de
pris la bonne décision
malgré la bonne décision parce que tu
t'en as musique
cette plateforme se font pas des
artistes c'est ça va former des
musiciens professeurs - kisten musiciens
professionnels se fait qu'au reste
stable
non merci tu vas voir tu vas y remédie
pas d'outil yano après ceux qui font
disparaître carrière puis qui sont
irréelles créatif pour qu'elle empêche
que hamiti traitement à prendre pour la
tête de plein doute sip investi quand je
chante dans ce texte il faut que je
passe ma place comme ça car chercher ce
le teint coffre d'outils tellement large
que tu sais plus lequel prod qui
voudrait pas que tu avais juste un outil
qu'ils allaient baisser piste et c'était
un outil qui est juste toi qui avait
plutôt que l'état le 12 mai elle mais
quand parce que je me suis fait mais ça
oui mais je comprends vraiment ce que
c'est difficile s'il se veut juste il
disait dans le fond l'auteur trop petit
pour ton heure pas vu ce que tu veux
c'est un outil pour toutes les images
ici qu'il tient pays qui ressemble à
aucun autre ne sont pas nombreuses mais
le pire semble à tout les outils qui
existent mais oui mais chez oui je
comprends pas complètement
cette analogie s'appuie maintenant sur
tout d'abord un coût d'achat ses ports
et ses comptes et d'avoir été plus
autodidacte parce que ce qui fait que
moi j'ai je me sens plus limité souvent
moi j'ai comme un berger
j'ai une certaine base qui est bonne ce
que j'ai fait du violent g j'étudie j'ai
fait de l'afflux traversé mon secondaire
mais j'ai peur j'ai pas les notions qui
fait que cg pas la facilité de faire
comme aux jeux faire cet accord
l'injection 7e ça va être fou c'est plus
cher juste mon piano je fais ça je
viendrai acheter ça c'est faux je suis
plus que je fais ouais mais ça sonne
bien
je fais ça que c'est plus ça c'est beau
c'est grand c'est ça me limite pas à
prayssas a fait que des fois j'arrive
avec les idées que je n'ai jamais pu
faire si j'avais eu comme en littérature
il ya déjà un prof qui m'a dit de
connaître les règles la littérature la
seule à faire que ça peut te permettre
de faire c'est de comprendre pourquoi
quelque chose ne fonctionne pas sauf que
si tu fais quelque chose instinctivement
puis ça fonctionne tout pas besoin de
comprendre pourquoi ça fonctionne pas
par contre si mettons tu fais quelque
chose peut maintenant moi je suis
mettons que je prends bien aux primaires
faire quelque chose publique
j'aurai ce ça marche pas genre cet
enchaînement la marche pas plus je veux
te voir toi je fais mais pourquoi ça
marche pas tout va être capable de
m'expliquer pourquoi ça marche pas
dessus mais si je fais quelque chose qui
fonctionne
j'ai pas besoin de personne m'expliquer
pourquoi tu sais pourquoi ça fonctionne
oui fait cinq ans que j'avais entendu ça
dans mes coups j'ai trouvé sur fascinant
parce que je m'étais dit effectivement
il ya plein d'auteurs plein d'écrivains
qui n'ont jamais étudié altéra turquie
prend maxi beaucoup de ces erreurs parce
comprennent pas pourquoi quelque chose
fonctionne pas qu'un rien aucun cas
changer temps de verbe si ça marche pas
pourquoi tu
mais thébaux savoir prendre un autre
temps de perdre quand celle là ça marche
ça crée de la petite magie ouais c'est
sûr le feu est très très variés we
phénix on va avoir plus instinctif
musicalement que d'autres c'est un
exemple comprendre qu'ils ont besoin
d'apprendre c'est moi mettons je sais
que tu es petit s'amusait si je te dis
mais tombe bien fait de petits tas
musique et moi si j'avais prédit des
remises et que je réponds mission
aujourd'hui j'avais peur comme pas pris
tant par georges jimi hendrix c'est vrai
mais c'est moi c'est lâche - qui a
fonctionné pour moi
pitié si différent aussi parce que
chaque instrumentiste je suis guitariste
puis mettons mois béton je suis pas mal
plus un corner que claudio sulser
mettons que que jean leloup pour être
sûr ma mamie yachts et non des jeux
savoir une partition devant lui puis de
rentrer dès qu au bon moment je pense au
québec
effectivement j'ai écouté j'ai beaucoup
que je parle je pense de sa cause de
jean leloup mais chez aux gémeaux
jusqu'à brûler web a eu un peu avant mes
amis font comme ils non voyante qui
vient sur l'estrade pour présenter un
prix puis l'homme véronique trottier a
dit on a fait les prochaines
présentations avec sait comment les
gains qui décrit les ce qui se passe à
trouver le volet pour les imac déception
en tout cas on a fait d'écrire par des
gens
les prochains nominés puis jean leloup
je pense qu'il faisait comme l'amour est
dans le pré où quelque chose capsule
c'est comme wall les oiseaux dans le
ciel bleu bleu la nature l'unique simon
une émission lors une télé réalité je
pense dans l'est marc cassivi qui
décrivait du langage non non c'était
vraiment pour les envoyant le fait que
c'était l'état qui sont je pense le fait
que jean leloup lyon comme dion comme du
demande à jean leloup parle par dessus
ces images mais effectivement que jean
leloup sur mon nom ça marchait pas aussi
mais tout ça c'est un contrat où tu as
besoin d'avoir tous les outils parce
qu'il a une tournée rock une tournée
acoustique hinton si nous y sommes il
faut tout prendre comme sur le dance
canada
c'est mon ex c'est super médiatisé this
way the remix manon premier tome mais la
cera d'y être parce que vous l'avez fait
en même temps qu'est ce qu'on ne fait
pas mieux oui c'est cela qui est fait
mais non on l'a vraiment mais on est
encore sans nom ses habitants plutôt
mixmania2 mais en été le phénomène et
c'est pour ça que mes yeux nous c'était
comme l'espèce de tel comeback
huit ans plus tard enfin que c'est toute
une nouvelle génération que pour eux
c'était là le premier pas que ça a quand
même été un pacte faustien pelo débat
lille ouais aussi aussi en ce compris
aux campeurs
vrai on est amis j'ai passé mon d'été
avec le gel et dans mon cas c'est
investi bon chanteur qui soit d'avoir
bonne musique dans ce show le christ n 6
de dassault et un essai un des baisses
le buzz pour faire ce qu'il veut puis
c'est lui a commencé il ya commencé à
chanter avec mixmania2 meilleur était
lui est rentré dans le show parce que
c'était un danseur nom et il était
capable de chanter mais je pense pas
qu'ils chantaient tongs savent pas que
pour lui c'était la découverte de son
potentiel chanteur lundi mais il a
commencé avec sa fac depuis une grande
évolution et puis il s'est mis à jouer
de la guitare puis ça a été vraiment
d'incidence de mixmania aujourd'hui qui
s'est développée musicalement mais avant
ça je pense pas qu'il faisait de temps
de musique moi c'est le contraire je ne
donne mais je ne danse pas plus le style
de jeu dans saint-aaron console quand on
sent des beaux objets 2 3 1 et qui
règlent ton ligne je te sors des rouges
c'est côté beauf mais je pourrais même
pas que je propose t montré d'ailleurs
il ya un ami en commun avec tu me
chasses à un chaman après que merriman
c'est c'est un ami de longue date
j'ai vu entendu mais c'est super bon
dans ça y est je pense que tu es en
révolution c'était mon voisin d'un
cheval mon voisin de qr devenus amis et
amants donné on s'était juste dit
rien toi lui et ne prennent guère d
amuser à ben on peut apprendre bière
dans ce message était comme chez eux en
vo à l'appartement du saint lô right on
prend un taxi
on s'en va juste les 2 le petit 1 à
nîmes c'est s'envoler et on le ramadan
c'est no life j'ai comme j'ai tellement
dense et ma vie ce soir et le pied puis
m'encourager victime faisait pas ce que
j'avais ces gens là les danseurs qui
sont incroyables mais tranquille
permanente au mondial n 5 lui même ce
tout dans ce port sentir comme ça
accroche quand je vois dans sa g and je
me sens de shit pour vraiment oui pige
pour l'offre des affaires tellement
assumer je pense que si j'étais un petit
oiseau avec soeur de mon corps jones un
jugement
y a rien comme une zone sans jugement
alors mesdames on est ce que tu sais que
tu peux faire n'importe quoi qui que
tout le monde
cinq cols s'il n'y a rien comme une zone
sans jugement choses vraiment pas si
vrai que il y en a pas de limites quand
tu te sens assez cuit mais en sécurité
c'est à dire que tout ce que ya pas de
limite à ce que tu peux faire dans ce
qui pousse bon
[Rires]
meiway avez vous des anges ou des
moments dans vos des oufs est elle c'est
fou mais en ce moment il y en a il y en
a pas de jugement c'est cool mais
j'avais cette discussion mais il ya eu
ma blonde jeu demain puis parce que l'on
met un mariage en fin de semaine puis on
a eu un mariage une coupe de deux mois
puis c'est avec ma gang d'amis du rouge
et or puis l'heure blond c'est quand je
faisais de la datation exacte mais quand
mes années universitaires
parce que sinon des années avant se tait
nous on y reste en contact on voit toute
la gamme du second temps et on ne deux
fois par année mais sinon j'en vois plus
tu es mes amis d'université puis quand
qu'on se revoie c'est vraiment sûr c'est
comme tout le monde à leur vie ont des
trucs t il un qui justement finances n'a
un autre qui est un ingénieur forestier
ne-yo qui tenait d'ailleurs civile et
renault travaille pour l'armée this to
come on y jobs était un parcours
différent des jobs bien placées dans
dans ville et puis quand on se retrouve
on devient les mêmes codes comme 20 ans
quand on s'est connu quand on sortait
aux stars war mettant les pieds on
retombe là comme si même un peu même
principe les cantons et mais c'est sûr
qu'il ya un peu juste nous dans ce bar &
blood à notre réunion de secondaire
parce que nos dons et à la réunion 2
secondes après on s'était dit on veut
que ça fasse comme comme si c'était hier
le second board s'est fait qu'on est
revenu un peu dans dans ces personnes là
puis on est un peu les seuls à avoir
prise wild monarch vous avez communiquer
votre idée ou non c'est un nom là
l'amant de jean loki retard vox la
petite chemise je salue jean ping a été
comme genre tout des fake mais meiway
cette zone là avec avec les guides du
rouge or ce cas c'est tout le temps
comme on peut faire ce qu'on veut le
titre ont peur de venir des phoques king
qui disent encore l'islande s'est piqué
4 voit quelqu'un que ça fait six ans que
prévu puisque si comme comment t'es tu
me prends la balle ou est ce qui est
commun des collections anglais j'aurais
pu reprendre la balle la balle au bond
ouais mais non c'est ce ccc une zone
zone fruits j'ai j'ai vécu sommes aussi
et il ya peut-être d'autres gars 3 1 je
ne veux pas radoter peut-être les jeux
les continents mais je pense pas mais
dans le fond et moi je viens de bromont
et puis il ya un bar à bromont c'est le
gars fait qu'à un moment donné je sors
avec des amis puis je recroise monde
jeunes du primaire du prime aux
primaires si gentil primeur de cette île
entends tu le disais pas vraiment et
parent et ben je sais pas s'il est
probable en mai par avait aucune bulle
ben moi je prends dans mes parents le
savez pas ce qu'est mon enfant de
michael badr us c'est lui et michael
roth album chez moi jamais les bonnes
c'était le dira
[Musique]
c'est le cha beau mais que puis son
meilleur ami chante que robben qui est
resté un très très bon ami lui c'est mon
premier job et après ça j'ai switché
pour mme call badauds bouchons à lui
mais ça ce qui me calme à dreuilhe mme
blanchet pas il m'a demandé de s'en
tirer avec genre on se parle chante avec
son ami non je pense qu'elle va évoluer
aspects de poids face à même année j'ai
j'ai laissé chambre je trouvais trop
sérieux était trop mathieu items à
rumeurs oui qui est plus jeune qu'elle
arrêtait pas de me parler ses jantes
aller au cinéma avec des amis toutes les
amies cours et profitent pas points
gâchés biais chan y avait les mains dans
les poches marché leurs manies par en a
commis était tellement matures puis ces
malades mais moi je t'ai pas le web tout
vous les petits gars qui crie trop fort
ouaip et qu'il faut la marche vraiment
est devenu mon petit chou sommes à un
moment donné il déménage à montréal qui
est on s'était donné rendez-vous dans
les estrades et un autre école primaire
puis 7 avant son départ j'avais de la
peine pièce son sac une bière mode hip
hop et qu'il avait pété mac os parce que
je peux pas croire que j'ai me souviens
m'être un trail le sait pas trop loin
oui je sais je me sentais le rail
ça n'a fait que j'ai vu est où le ca
cola bien moi j'essaie de la ville ce
soir et le belge et comme on se tait
pour moi c'était outre un je sais pas
pourquoi je sais pas pourquoi je savais
dans ma été éteintes plus installé
civitas reporter mon jeu parfait qui et
c'est ce qui est trop beau ou plutôt tu
devais la première bière cse
dosanjh a vendu 24 bref tout ça pour
rené à jaillir croisé où est garé à un
moment donné plan nord si on serait mort
in obese amis quand c'est dit elle ça
serait malade faire retrouvailles de la
sixième année
mais cette année c'est loin leurs traces
et seulement le règle ont fait cette
blague le mécréant écrit le groupe
facebook vient vite tout le monde comme
les fouaces la soixantaine d'élèves de
la chantignole l'invite sur le vite les
gens sur le groupe
et finalement ça s'écroule une semaine
plus tard on n'avait fait qu'un produit
est méfiante à lécher française binaire
comme tout ça pas de bon sens pour moi
c'est mes amis du prix marqué j'ai
jamais revu on sait tout sépare et on
taille dans les écoles différentes
on s'est donné rendez-vous dans son
change chez francis à faire un feu de
camp qui moi je me souviens de m'être
demandé avant d aller en terre loto avec
mes amis du primaire glenz et puis
alexandre gagnon n'a tenté que vous avez
vu comme ça en valeur la musique dans le
tapis en spray puis j'avais peur que ça
soit les magasins de pasquasy on se
connait pu mais au contraire on est
arrivé là
tout le monde était tellement content de
se voir au pied on est comme on est
revenu parce qu'on était en 6e année on
a passé la soirée à jouer à tag nu pieds
dans un champ il y avait des lucioles
j'ai retrouvé des amis comme on se
tenait même on capte des gens c'est
viscéral j'ai réalisé que mes amis du
primaire ont un peu forgé la personne
que j'étais à prêt puis après je me suis
développé sur mon second avec mes amis
sont là mais j'ai la zac est passé à
milan et est important c'est comme si on
s'était jamais quitté 1 ça faisait des
années tic qui après coup ben il ya un
des amis de la gagne qui est devenu mon
coloc qui devenait une meilleure amie
qui est devenu un doute super important
avec qui j'allais alten beach haïti
comme ça ça fait son petit bout de
chemin et pim ça comme ouvert d
plett un premier temps est venu de voir
partir chez moi faites encore là même
coup mis en danger
quand je termine adeptes l'habillage pas
cessé depuis le temps
c'est si j'ai juste eu le flash parce
que tu disais tu es tu arrives leur
inquiétude vite taris la soirée comme ça
craque et une des raisons en fait la
raison principale que nous on est autant
le feu dans le temps retrouvé
c'était parce qu' on s'était dit
ensemble peu importe qu est ce qui
arrive on va avoir du fun puis on est
arrivé de la marde les mains du gang
sont me sont faites m -of baird les yeux
il y avait les faits avant un smoky
machine à fumée et l'on parti à s'arrête
et plus ça s'est mis à sonner les
alarmes les pompiers n'ont été dans un
petit local
le pad à québec déjà il y avait
tellement de boucane mettons en soit pas
loin si l'adema si nous on n'a même pas
pris en considération ces jolies voulait
casser les parties plus genre getty eu
la bisbille apprend certaines personnes
qu'il faut toujours tout ancien col s'il
est en effet on voit pied sur saint-jean
huawei plus la soirée avançait moins
événements restent les meilleurs sont
une personne complètement mais c'est fou
ce qu'un mindset peu fade
oui mais un vous le vous avez consulté
personne mais vous êtes vous êtes mis
dans cet état n'a volume de salades quoi
le modèle qu'il yad'autres soir it's as
tu sais pas pourquoi mais travers d'un
clip à la csu si justement une question
de cette hormone question 27 mai les
soirées où est ce que je me dis ça me
tente pas juge la médecin jamais jamais
jamais que je vois même pas dessus est
de démystifier
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'avant partir et
europol ou est ce que c'est à cause
d'une journée qui est moins bien est ce
à cause des
jean stu est ce qu'une angoisse qui
viennent soit il ya souvent souvent les
personnes qui mettent leurs foins c'est
souvent les personnes qui est ancrée et
ses méthodes pour reprendre cet exemple
chez avec dans l'être peu importe qui
sera l'espace et puis j'avais peut être
dans le même état d'esprit moins qu'en
mai ton je me dis on va dans un bar il
ya plein d'enfants que je contrôle pas
moi je m'aperçus socialement impliqué
fake je contrôle pas aussi forte
roulement ça c'est la première affaire
qui - vent fort que je vous offre
complète ya trop de monde c'est quelque
chose qui est romancier du monde dames
ont dans ma bulle vraiment le sait
vraiment non faut juste de quoi après
fermin ma part la deuxième affaire c'est
qu'ils vont être là la troisième force
est ce qu'on est capable de parler dans
ces soirées si la musique est trop forte
parce qu'en ces points chauds mettons le
site un dj qui est loeb quitte même si
le bébé était bon mais qui était comme
celle espèce de zone en quad
mais passé avec son ami rahman puis
allez dans cet avis mais tu vois et
mettons un dj killer mais l'espèce on a
quoi on est assis genre l'ange ouais
mais pour tikrit demain matin quand un
pote sort de l'autre plus de voix mais
c'est un mois mais en même temps j'ai
pas danser mais le plan bien ça c'est
des ambiances of cesser les ambiances
que tu ne recherche pas océans ou
l'autre souci pendant une si ce n'est
toi tu es quelqu'un tu sais que probant
de belles soir il faut que jose 6 jaune
poussin pas complices tous impôts bien
et c'est sûr que d'aller dans des
endroits comme ça c'est un peu qu elle
soit peu cul mais en même temps
atari tout défaut de farges ans et moins
j'ai même je m'en crisse jasp au chaud
ou un faux choix chaud pour faire ça
parce que je regarde de faire ce support
de logements
les blues my soul to dance et comme
l'autre fois j'ai lose my love to dance
au chalet david on a vu david parce
qu'il ya comme il y avait du pote du
capitaine du ring ring c'est comme je
sais bd c'est super doux pelage et comme
s'effectue pas ce genre de demande
je déconne j'ai juste comme cette salle
en salle on plonge dans ses demandes
la pression est allé comme en bateau sur
le lac mais dans un bar quand je pose
chaud je loue ce pauvre gars comme trop
d'éléments qui deviennent un sujet
devienne anxiogène ou irritant mais
berdych excuse même principe dans un
spectacle j'ai de la misère comme plus
j'ai plus je vieillis plus j'ai de la
mesure allait voir un show live juste
parce que il ya trop d'affaires qui me
sortent de la musique je vois comment
dire sur le puits peut-être que c'est
une question brûle encore une fois quand
même oui pour ces affaires lui mais j'ai
trop d'affaires qui me sort des musées
je veux voir un show pour l'artiste il
ya trop d'enfants qui met loin des
artistes comme dans un jeu l'estac mais
c'est moi même qui est ma passion
presspass la musique des photos voir un
show puis après une heure c'est comme
ouais pas mal de gens pas comme pas
vraiment les paroles c'est ya du monde
qui me pose si je vois un gars devant
moi qui me cache une lumière qui me
ramenait en face il fait chaud kim et on
t'aime tellement tu es bon niveau et moi
derrière album c'est drôle que tu disais
ça dans ma tête en synchro j'ai dit je
me suis dit au passage en face à ben
c'est sûr parce que lui mettons
maintenant j -christophe je suis couchée
dans mon lit je marche l'automne août et
puis
c'est juste la meilleure expérience que
je peux vivre
j'aurais pas de meilleure expérience en
le voyant life as we des chocs et des
fois je travaille à imaginer quand on
parle de voir des fois il était un
chopper tgt comme en transe pu laisser
comme ça lui aussi des choses que tu es
comme bon je pensais que j'allais
capoter c'est comme bon j'ai une de mes
amis c'est la personne la plus
extraordinaire roman je peux si tu vu
peut-être sûrement instagram nina sont
japonaises pet sont mal mais elle c'est
la personne la plus incroyable et elle
est d'une pureté qui disent il a
expliqué al peuple a besoin de rien pour
être à l'apogée donen de son émotion
c'est vraiment impressionnant puis c'est
un carnet est juste à la grandeur des
mesures et puis est juste tellement
belle qui est allé à chaque année puis
je m'appelle piste et c'était bien moi
je ne connais pas de temps mais en l'air
c'était incroyable c'est vraiment une
belle expérience et on n'a pas vu leur
visage une fois cdc des lumières de
dauphin kg et à contre-jour piste était
juste en noir piste est vraiment c'était
vraiment bon pis le son était super bon
qui sait moi je trouvais content d'être
le pij accepter tout ce qui arrive et je
trouve ça super
mais elle elle et elle ne le veut à un
haut niveau et elle ne fait pas de
drogue juste le mentionner l puis je
sais exactement l été ou dans son corps
mais elle va tout mais avec plein d'amis
alentours elle n'avait besoin
d'approbation de personnes et elle était
toute seule avec elle même en train de
vivre une espèce de connexion intense
jeu les jupes et bien vous prenez la
musique de même si je la voyais puis à
la prenez la musique le pied à vivait
quasiment un orgasme genté plat marc
galtier crampons pis si je le savais
qu'elle avait vécu quelque chose de
super intense que ça lui appartenait
pied
c'est juste qu'on dirait qu elle capable
d'atteindre un espèce de niveau 2 génère
un ex lève comme comme quand tu fais
dans drogue pour vivre sans elle elle
vit naturellement ces malades parce que
moi mettons même si j'aurais le goût le
genre à douvres et mes bras comme celui
de faire genre ce que tu en communion
avec les moments je me dirais tu as de
la casse ces malades est capable
d'entrer d'amazon de genre par le toit
mais même chose pour toi puis moi c'est
ça arrive trop souvent dans un dans un
quotidien où on est comme moi j'ai pas
capable d'embarquer dans le moment parce
que j'ai cette déconnexion la dépense et
kaki ou de parts ou juste moi même de
m'imposer ce jugement-là à moi même qui
le pire dans ce domaine kit auto jules
très dont un jugement tout le temps
c'est la zone sans jugement qu'on
parlait tant tous les apports de soie le
lin postaux jugeant que les soucis oui
mais trop mais c'est parce qu'on ait
peur sa part de la peur on a peur de se
faire juger on est on ne part de pau est
adéquat mais après ce cycle
c'est vraiment le pire parce qu'on est
les seuls à ce médecin à se mettre cette
limitation le site demain matin tu avais
envie de faire comme un mois maintenant
j'ai terminé de définir mes réactions
parce que les gens pourraient peut-être
penser de moi je fais un espèce de 180
puis je me concentre là dessus puis à
limite je fais de la méditation pressé
d'aller rechercher le autant que
possible cette facette de moi je
persuadé qu'on peut on peut y arriver
c'est comme une manière pour moi ça ce
que c'est un peu une cas être de 4
d'évolution j'aimerais en ce moment je
suis seul mais il ya toujours on peut
toujours s'améliorer qui est inhumain
meilleur pied pas de limite à être
meilleur mais y'a pas c'est demain à pau
perfectionnisme que je donne mais c'est
juste moi je vois mon amie nina wang
compris quelque chose puis c'est ça la
has est innée on dirait le mais on peut
vraiment être qu'on veut de nous sur
quoi tu travailles pour être meilleur
en ce moment soit je travaille beaucoup
sur je réalise que j'ai des parts
injustement des patins kim chi qui me
freine beaucoup surtout premier termine
je réalise que dans mes relations
amoureuses
je sais pas ça vient d'où mais je pense
que je suis quelqu'un qui est assez
droites dans la vie par rapport à ce que
je veux je sais ce que je veux je sais
ce que je veux pas j'ai pas difficulté
on en parle et je pense que j'ai une
bonne communication avec les gens que
j'aime ma famille mes amis
après ça quand je tombe dans l'amour
le spectre de l'amour il ya un truc
chimiques ou je sais pas ce qui se passe
mais je perds le contrôle de mon être un
peu ce qui fait que des réactions ou
demi réaction de de ma manière de
communiquer jeu mais je tombe comme un
espèce de gouffre d'insécurité et de
juste deux ans vrai que j'ai comme vécu
des quelques expériences amoureuses qui
font que maintenant il ya certains
comportements qui me fige le système
fige le jetant dans un autre monde comme
ok mais le spica de communauté monsieur
communique plus je peux vraiment partir
en couille demain pilote je réalise que
j'ai des patins ou je peux être
exigeante dans certaines facettes ou
séparément si ça découle d'une certaine
peur de me faire avoir août et c'est
tout ce qui est en train de décortiquer
s'étoffe un peu basses attaques et les
choses qui sont arrivées c'est dur de
s'en défaire selon exactement selon
l'apec
puis de retour oui puis j'ai comme le
lâcher prise aussi le laisser khaliqi de
ne pas exiger d'une autre personne a son
histoire à elle aussi puis ça fait que
qui ont leur raison d'être et de dans la
réaction une raison d'être est tous avec
moi j'ai de la misère aussi à décrocher
de sappi tout est gros petit hic je veux
donner près du rhin main sans doute
vouloir trop intense entre investi le
temps tu veux trop au dessus
j'arrive pas à me détacher d'une
situation donc c'est moi avec mes amis
le ma famille c'est quelque chose qui
fonctionne pas je peux être directive
ouais tu peux oui je sais toujours de le
faire de manière la plus douce pour pau
agressé personne puis que ça mais je le
dis qu'il ya quelque chose puis
justement puisque je suis détaché que
c'est grâce à ça fonctionne pas sa peau
ce qui alimente printemps qu'il faut
reviens moi quand on est prêt à le
prendre mais en amour c'est trop à
l'extrême laxisme s'ils sont là mais
espèce de de patin sur quoi j'ai envie
de travailler de pu me laisser moto
perdre parce qu'un coup je me perds là
j'ai l'impression de me faire avoir deux
partout parce que je me sens qu accès
juste rester graver des cd c'est de
trouver les outils pour ne plus même
dans ces situations la page et parce que
le jeu réalise que je sais un patin en
autorités régionales beaucoup de monde
qui ont des relations et non mais c'est
parce qu'il faut que ça think in le
monde à la maison qui nous écoutent la
maison les 6,5 et ce par un patin ça se
développe de façon quand même insidieuse
avec ton bagage pitt et moi tout le
monde le trauma gage de toute façon les
tuer dans tous les cas du tout et
expériences passées qui font que tu
réagisses d'une certaine façon tu
appliques tu appliques des comportements
aux gens que je côtoie des comportements
quelqu'un d'autre avait avant fait
extrapole un petit peu une situation
donnée
puis j à cause qu'ils savaient plus tôt
pas de casque on retombe à 17 jours de
zone le des psychologies jeux d'écriture
de réinviter psychologue explique
suppose pas la femme qui ont fait des
théories mais parce que bah oui mais on
évitera d'autres maillots mais si cet
été c'est cette offre un cri s'est
débarrassé d'un patron puis n'est pas
trop d'un batteur pas trop mais j'ai
l'impression que faut pas non plus
penser qu'on a besoin de se débarrasser
tous nos patins parce que c'est pas tout
les patins qui sont négatives c'est pas
tous les patterns kitty chaque personne
un code moral c'est chaque personne oui
les frontières d'amoralité peuvent se
déplacer
par contre les deux affaires qui
prendront jamais qui rendent au jazz
exact mais des affaires que toi puis moi
c'est quelque chose que j'apprends
beaucoup maintenant c'est de dire
respecte la personne qui était devenu
way respecte la personne qui était
devenu plus que tu le fais maintenant
parce que c'est toi tu respectes pas la
personne que tu es devenu parti
expérience tout seul on peut toujours
s'améliorer le disent pas ce que je dis
on les personnes de figer le pied sauf
que respecte quand meme l'accumulation
des expériences
dis-toi pas si ça ça me fait chier parce
que j'ai vécu ça / / / se sait pas
nécessairement négatif c'est toi ça te
fait chier l'accumulation des événements
la fecq la situation dans laquelle tu
vis présentement savait pas des limites
à toi puis si tu respectes la personne
qui était devenu tu respectes que tu
t'étais dit oui où la personne morale
que tu es devenu cela respecte assez tu
as fait c'est quoi ce même si c'est un
patin qui fait que j'accepte parce ça se
peut que que ce soit correct que ce soit
en partie mais sa fille ce qui ce que tu
es aussi un pc c'est exactement faut
être méchant je vais vraiment qu'est ce
que tu dis tu sais c'est pas non plus de
de tomber dans un espèce de quête de
j'échoue et pour cause si ça fonctionne
pas avec cette personne là c'est parce
que j'ai un problème puis je travaille
sont maintenant en fait moi le
là le patton devient un quelque chose à
traiter sais où je prends conscience que
ça me nuit à moi même parce que c'est
oui je sais que je viens avec un certain
caractère qui qui fort à certains
moments qui les passe à d'autres puis
juge comme ceux qui je vais pas non plus
tomber dans la machine mais mais par
contre je de savoir maintenant que j'ai
que j'ai dit qu'aux certains
comportements qui me nuisent à moi même
avant même de nuire un couple ou à une
amie tiguan c'est là où je suis a acquis
mais au moins c'est bien un cadeau mais
deux doigts dessus tu es tout neuf
titres phares qui ont les moyens de ne
plus me laisser rentrer dans certaines
dans certaines et dans certains conflits
t non par moi même ouais ouais vous la
première étape mais aussi ses limites en
ce que tu écrivais ça c'est l'éternelle
question quand et un couple on dirait
pic
il ya des conflits dont les choses
fonctionnent peu plus et le
questionnement tout le temps et esquisse
d'un site ou moi le problème ou basse et
l'autre problème ouais si c'est juste
pour un bon fils qui des fois c'est de
l'incompatibilité puis à 0 pourquoi
vouloir mais on a chacun nos bacs hommes
qui font que ab on ça fonctionne pas
c'est souvent c'est souvent ceux en fait
à moins qu'ils aient vraiment à aider
des comportements qui des relations en
relation c'est comme tout le temps dans
la sphère le tribun qui était mannequin
quand ça sent la merde partout où tu
veux mais mais mais c'est ça des fois ci
incompatibilité ou bien faut-il
culpabiliser parce que tu penses que
c'est aucun problème d'enfants peut
nécessairement séparément je pense que
de l'aide gones dans des leds dans ces
moments là où tu ton
mais comme tu disais la dtcc à lire
d'amour et plus
c'est vraiment espèce de sentiment
d'urgence que les choses qui
fonctionnent pas ou parce que les
anciennes amours cette folle de la bonne
entente et ses soeurs mail est un ch'ti
ça peut être destructrice oui mais un
fake
des fois tu y étais mieux d'aller au
début les détacher je pense que c'est la
bonne chose a dream était mieux d'être
avoir un regard un peu plus posé sur
toutes ces affaires le objectif qui est
déjà sa balle et moi même si c'est dur à
dire jusqu'à ce qui s'est vraiment plus
facile à dire qu'à faire
facile à dire qu'à la sceptique j'ai
l'impression sur tout et avec le je sais
pas comment dire sur vraiment mais j'ai
l'impression que les gens qui
s'attachent trop à certaines relations
puis de vouloir à tout prix de battre
caen au final tu dis et c'est peut-être
pas ton combat je t'ai parlé de mon ami
jeff qui étaient quittées sur un
monsieur dans le bain mais qui dit
grande prestation
ouais je rencontre esthéticiens intégral
benne puis on a cliqué dessus depuis j'y
parlais beaucoup j'espère vraiment
beaucoup voire à 8 puis l'autre jour
yemba toujours mobilisés dans la vida il
faut apprendre à laisser aller aux
petites phrases puis j'ai compris ce
qu'est ce qu'on les a par le biais
raison chose certaine que cette
intervention le pour toi eu l'effet que
ça avait besoin de frappe ou peut-être
de 7
deux suppléments pas un bon pour ça que
c'est chiant parce que le temps cédé
seconde piste comme c'est long mais le
temps habituellement de deux expériences
ça a été vraiment bénéfique thé épicé
c'est vraiment une petite magie tu fais
quand même en donner ou la pression
redescend
ouais ça peut paraître plus gros c'est
que c'est quoi c'est quand tu montes une
roche sur une montagne là
qu'apparaissent internet est totalement
au plan de la roche laroche cc nogent on
est là on en est là aujourd'hui je sais
moi la loge comprends pas c'est bon ça
paraît c'est drôle ça paraît qu'on se
pose des questions ça c'est quand même
année sa 100e sélection ses cuisses le
sans-fil pas casqué du tradi s'était
[Rires]
enfin quatre comme bailleur tout le
monde et s'est amusé le nom de la
nouvelle merge des cristaux moi c'est
dominique pied
je sais que ça des emprunts les appels à
kas vient avec
[Rires]
juste non non mais de quoi est ce que
genre tu vas pendant fucking deux
semaines puis tu te lèves le matin puis
j'en suis mange des fruits sur la cale
qui prend des fois tout petit
pourcentage non non non celui là mais
j'ai fait c'est récemment un mini tueur
de hawaii five-o à la tuque peas a été
un trois jours de ses ballons trop
journée
ça paraît pas de téléphone ça a été
genre vraiment vraiment vraiment
bénéfique pour moi 2 2 décroché puis
honnêtement c'est de savoir que j'avais
peur que j'en avais pas mal fait mon
téléphone et je sais dans mon sac
pendant trois jours je les jeux les même
pas sorti une fois puis j'ai pas eu
besoin de d'aller voir c'est quoi qui se
passait au contrat je prenais tout ce
que j'avais à ce moment le jeu vive et
puis un moment donné qu'on est là la
journée qu'on est partis légaux sont
échangés sont importés les poubelles qui
montre atteint ici le chéquier toutes
les fenêtres fermées
ça a pris plus de temps va-t-on en faire
un détour au village mais on peut d'ici
puissent aller chercher de l'argent
là je restais quand même vraiment un bon
45 minutes assises sur le perron sur une
balançoire de peyron avec mylo on chez
qui j'ai juste pris ce moment là parce
que ça me tombe dans les trois jours on
était tous des amis cac ait pas eu de
moment seulement cela mais là j'ai comme
j'avais ma fin de semaine dans le corps
tout le bagage à 26 semaines qui est le
pij juste véhicules - à contempler avons
rien d'autre que moi sur une chaise
d'abord les sens tellement des baux sont
dans la nature
puis j'ai mon chien je contemple ne pas
avoir le réflexe mais les fans qui dans
une chaise berçante à un téléphone c'est
comme messi c'est moi ça me fait de la
ca me fait peur qu'est ce qu'on en a une
si on souffre tout d'une dépendance à la
technologie presque 2 décembre la
première à haïr les faits qu'on compte
sur nos téléphones
la première est comme un alcoolique qui
détestent l'alcool le trimaran forme il
devrait avoir d'aidé que c'est vrai mais
je m'étais dit de faire ce jeu persuadé
en plus qui en sortant du bois quatre
points essentiels de réaliser que tu
avais rien manquer exactement ça c'est
la plus grande réalisation
mais je les fait une fois qui depuis je
le fais à microdoses de mettre en cage
va courir j'amène pas mon fils tu prends
pas de musique
l'autre jour j'ai fait 35 km de course
sans musique sans rien juste ceci comme
une juste une micro doses de été raclés
c'est mon seul chez nous puis de pas y
penser que des fois c'est quand même
c'est ce que j'entendais mon canapé est
chauvin tarifs chez vous c'est comme
deux messages non lus pige au micro d'i
c'est vraiment mini latine sauf que est
en sable plus grande était ferme
concerts pendant trois jours qu'est ce
que tu manges oui c'est surtout qui est
il le fait se défasse houston c'est
important dit que donc on a tous eu de
match et qui sont fabriqués son
téléphone se sait quand des fêtes départ
terne aussi que de nouvelles choses qui
arrivent d'une vérité telle est béton
sur ta chaise berçante premièrement
c'est un souvenir que te reste évitons
celle très peu de souvenirs le lot qui
gérait des 45 minutes puis je me suis
juste bercy puis j'écoutais les oiseaux
puis contempler la nature retient de
beckham a quitté st
mais sait-on ce genre seraient tombées
malades n'ont pas évaporée serait pas
resté dans sa tente et souvenirs comme
un bon moment
puis je me souviens c'est trop jour du
lot eu des réflexions ou des idées
peut-être écrit où je poste et les cris
des enfants étaient peut-être fait des
choses qui justement qui sont pas des
patins de l'habituel petit temps appris
à mieux connaître ses futurs jeux et un
autre moment
c'est notre printemps on venait
d'arriver puis un ponton fait que l'on
s'en va sur le pont temps avec l'alcool
pour le coucher du soleil
[Musique]
12 c'est doux puis c'est comme c'est pas
comme il juge ce qui inclut on est là en
plein milieu du lac
on n'avait pas de téléphone on les avait
fait je dirais on n'a pas droit et
femmes on peut quand même ils ont des
photos sinon il n'avait pas mené dans le
ponton vous avez laissé dans la maison
et tu sais j'ai vu le plus beau coucher
de soleil de ma vie eagle mais vous
comprenez papier c'est un lac je pense
que peut-être dix résidences
il n'y a pas deux comme il ya peu c'est
juste beau tu vois quelques chalets mais
c'est vraiment son oeuvre de paix puis
on est un peu mieux du lac puis le
soleil le ciel réflétait sur l'eau qui
comme tant de temps je regardais dans
quatre endroits le cd comme sur 360
degrés qui avait pas un crime qui était
pareil en avait dit tout ça c'est un
souvenir que je suis neutre sur le
ponton de me dire j'aurais tellement
aimé son pouvoir le prendre en photo
parce que j'ai honnêtement jamais vu un
aussi beau coucher de soleil même si
j'étais un peu en bois sont même si t'es
juste est c'était hors de soi puis après
coup j'ai fait mon four ne m'en fous
parce que en ce moment j'y repense qui
c'était trop beau il dit
c'est ce puits est intact dans tes
souvenirs parce qu'en photo sur
l'injustice en plus et un peu mieux ce
fait c'est même moi quand je regarde les
photos de voyage me dis que cela c'est
le plus beau paysage que j'ai vu de ma
vie pour regarder photoshop est assez
beau c'était pas si c'est un peu comme
être l'été
il faut être là puis les photos c'est le
fun j'ai rien contre les phototypes
système à limite important de capturer
certainement mal mais justement tant que
j'ai deux soleils
il va rester parfait c'est le genre de
moment août
heureusement un thrill hall un genre de
walker comme quand on bosse là sur la
route de de beauté y avait comme ces
foulées gueule et y avait à côté austère
aux prêts sa cause qui avait des nuages
de ce texte un fuchsia comme avec plein
de lait oeufs l'aut'bord c'était un
genre de move avec des tout petits
nuages fait que c'était comme thème
raison de perdre qui en arrière c'est un
bleu gris profond mais ça avait cessé il
faut prendre le temps de regarder couché
sur les 30 ans puisse à ce genre de
choses qui étaient n'importe qui ça
planète la mode est mort à l'intérieur
vos s'entend sur le fait que ces boules
c'est qu'est-ce qui fait quelque chose
et baumes et en mettant la table je peux
trouver belle tout pas trouvé en chine
un coucher de soleil le programme en 10
mois que je salue sa mère tabarnak de la
bourre mais oui c'est comme si
objectivement nos petits plats dans les
grands
si l'humanité c'est la beauté du monde
c'est comme c'est tellement puissant qui
s'est depuis je prends sur moi je prends
pas certain dans ma vie pour contempler
de la façon que je les fait cette fois
le sur le bateau mais mais on devrait
essayer on devrait prendre le temps de
regarder la nature puis de d'avoir
aucune pensée juste là regardez écoutez
j'ai fait un voyage ensemble php
d'autres amis quand même un bon bout de
temps
80 moi bien chaque soir de ckac et le
soleil qui ont été secourus depuis que
le monde allait sera un tri pour se
préparer avant le souper y mettons - ph
piano de nos amis en face aux lycéens
plage tenter quelque chose olé à chaque
sorte de rituel propose tranquille
contempler le boat
ouais
larry king dans son dernier run avec sur
l'album de l'art d'albums
la turn off the grid idylle de joie
paraphraser parce que je la laissais
surface intègre à dix elle frôle
promouvant la vie rapide c'est aussi
rien qu'ici au chalet je sais tu peux tu
peux vivre mon lieu de travail et
forking former les foi se ressourcer le
pire rien qu'à réception on essayait de
le bouquet pour le podcast c'est de la
plus petite et mettons ce soit je
proposais d' peu de ce soir pizza man
show shine et puis j'ai juste de dire je
suis au chalet et le ghost un rapport
ligne de linge juste de m
je suis au footing chez elle et son
album sort dans deux mois ces étudiants
il faut que je prépare ce fou je
pratique le ghetto chalet où j'allais le
stress et le c de la marne faut savoir
arrêter
oui je pense que je pense que c'est
nécessaire puisque si tu le fais pas tu
peux pas tu peux pas c'est moi ça fait
pas longtemps que je suis vraiment
occupé genre à côté ça fait peut-être
deux trois ans mais depuis new delhi que
j'en suis à côté parce que c'est moi ma
vie avec un homme je m'entraîne et
j'allais à l'école piste et de la ccsa
choisi mais depuis que je suis à côté je
me dis admettons que je pense que j'ai
pris des poses puis pas des vrais pause
puis je me dis je pourrais pas continuer
comme cela cinq lancers qui a changé
c'est devenu travailleur autonome c'est
que changer point qu'à travers autonome
c'est que tout le temps peu de temps
faire plus tout à une pression d'enfer
plus citoyens et les filles mais signale
tu veux pas être la bonne place au bon
moment de deux gouttes d'eau
toto créer c'est comme mais je comprends
je me suis même temps je me dis je
continue comme ça sans faire plus
attention pas trop mal dans cinq ans
je c'est fini c'est fini je suis plus
capable de rien faire je le vois déjà
même jeu dans cinq ans mais c'est comme
basque et scénario parce que tu sais ça
me fait pas plus attention maintenant au
buisson il faut savoir s'arrêter parce
que je sais pas si tu es seul des trois
quarts des cas mais non non non non
parce que j'en ai moi des amis qui sont
comme ça puis que je constate tout ce
que sait puisque ça fait carrément donné
c'est que débarque pis c'est juste trop
pis si ça fait un trou principaux bon
c'est pour maïwenn juste comme de
prendre un petit moment une fois de
temps en temps pour revenir à ramener à
zéro puis juste plus apte à être
performants ont fait faux soccer levé ce
qu'on dit au début que c'était utile aux
bas salaires s'est enquis compris le
prétendu lillois n'attendaient même pas
quelqu un livre cbi dit mettons sa
création c'est aussi ces mamans de
chicxulub la chichon de ça fait
longtemps que cherche de la métaphore se
démarquer chile chico sa campagne puis
la hiérarchie à hiérarchiser mai
mais moins cesser ces moments là le sont
aussi importants que genre que tu penses
que tu fais quoi de productivité mois
d'arrêt le moment juste de contemplation
le moment que tu lis tu te fait quoi
pour toi mais après ça nourrit peu
importe la façon qui ne serait ce que de
réussites nous c'est faux je pense
qu'une balance vous soyez niant ces faux
pas trop cheap le porte monnaie des fois
je l'espère mais après ça c'est juste de
trouver tombale envie de te faire
attention parce que ça vieillit vite en
temps quand tu es stressé puis tu vois
pas le temps passer pikine amante et 50
hors caisse ça allait vite que j'ai pris
le temps d'arrêter de son original the
way on fait rien que le dpp sortie de
fêter lancement j'ai quelques dates
maison je sais pas s'ils sont confirmés
je veux faire mais je veux faire mon
show est cet hiver qu'on va monter quand
elle juste agrémenter un peu parce que
la date je performe et chansons puis
j'apprends à connaître mon terrain de
jeu mais j'ai pas de mise en scène quoi
que ce soit je monte mon show je veux
seulement faire une truc pour m pour
montréal mais je peux encore de
confirmation de date que je sais pas
encore je vais chanter avec alex nevsky
aussi om telus pour son show j'ai pas la
data vault bien je me mets bien on écrit
une chanson ensemble c'est quelques mois
lui en femme est arrivée avec une
chanson qui avait produites avec 512 et
comme dernière gagné la dernière excuse
moi gamin secteur des objets puis
voulait qu'il voulait qu'on chante cette
chanson l'ensemble dans le même il me
donnait la liberté ii de faire mon
veulent mélodiquement et paroles fac ça
c'est vraiment cool fallait finalement
de comme cette petite collaboration là
l'atout de sortir éventuellement et
jonathan dessous ouais c'est cool c'est
c'est très cool c'est c'est un groupe
qui me ressemble je suis me semble que
je vois les gens tant que mal les mecs
là mais ça me rend trop curieux soit
être franglais et ben en fait ils
chantent leurs frais en anglais six ans
après en x qui intègre d'engrais de lang
lang
ben moi je chantais francs franglais ok
c'est le français et l'anglais dans
mauvaise foi que je veux chanter avec
lui pour son show ce nom là on est
retourné dans le processus
on a recommencé à écrire moins connue je
revienne cette semaine à toronto on est
qui ce projet ça me semble être le genre
de l'oft jeune et très comme salon style
bien vous êtes le genre c'était vraiment
cool on est parti quatre jours qu'ils
ont c'est loin bien dit on à cette opé
notre notre studio qui on a fait venir
deux curateurs de toronto parce que
depuis début lucky man on travaille que
que nous deux et puis finalement on
avait le goût des sites décide quelque
chose de nouveau le temps d'intégrer des
gens juste ne serait-ce que j'ai des
idées pid d'amener encore plus de gens
talentueux exactement ce qu'on a fait ça
a été vraiment cool très différent comme
approche mais mais vraiment bien il ya
dans cette chanson que j'aime beaucoup
et qu'on va finir par produire mais pas
qu'on recommence et l'espèce de 2 c que
le d'écriture
et ça marche parce que vous avez vécu
d'études mes tongs et de voix au piano
voix peu après ce vous lancer dans la
production ocde
ça dépend c'est tout le temps ça dépend
vraiment il ya des fois où on arrive en
studio puis stephen scratch l'on
commence de rien pions j'habite le genre
c'est ouais ouais ouais je trouve le
synthétiseur pigboss il lui prend la
guignolade ce n'est qu' on en est simple
un qui moi j'entendais des x cse des
fois c'est moi qui fais des petites
maquettes à la maison vraiment mais ça
fonctionne liste des sons leur plus on
part de ce bras toronto mais c'était une
nouvelle approche c'était de partir de
rien mais au lieu de faire de la
production et d'ensuite faire des
mélodies et les paroles c'est d'écrire
une chanson qui va décrire un texte des
deux factions d'une chanson guitare voix
c'est juste différent produisent au
québec avant sa partie plus du bit pas
prévoir ajoute la voix les parents se
sont créés comme une base avec des
accords qu'on aimait un vibe puis on
jamais des mauges que jamais des
mélodies lui aussi souvent lui c'est il
ya en temps des fêtes mais tant que j'ai
ramené votre copie ordas date secours
nous est il encore à kiel on
enregistrait sa plus il y avait une
mélodie qui fixait comme plus décousu
mais finalement on travaille tellement
fort après sarah lane a amené un texte
qui était propre à ce que j'avais envie
de dire on travaille là dessus ce qui a
donné des toons très intègre quand même
ses mails
la raison de penser c'était différent
c'était plus vraiment de com de
construire une chanson intégral sont
retenus auront tout le temps a été assez
cool way fait qu'on a fait son oeuvre en
essayant de 3 tonnes qu'il veut je veux
demander à voir l'amour nous de la
preuve et le gisti go qui sort bientôt
ouais
nouvelle affaire genre commence à sortir
des affaires bientôt des enfants cette
fois ci on fera pas de clip pour celle
là mais je pense qu'on va avoir beaucoup
de visuels
parce que les un clip c'est un bonbon
c'est le fun c'est comme ça c'est un une
ambiance bien un temps sauf que c'est ça
c'est coûteux puis de nos jours et même
avec instagram et où on peut vraiment
vous savoir info kembo visuel qui
représente bien la chanson je pense
qu'on va opter pour ce mais j'aimerais
entrer aussi parce qu'on voulait sortir
dans genre un mot 2 cuil
ouais moi un mois je pense qu'on a ça
mais ton show live commence à se déploie
mettons ces dessus toi d'être acquitté
berne coire gr b on est trop fin quand
j'ai dromer qu'ils based in puis aussi
liquide puis qui s'occupe des séquences
j'ai beaucoup de séquences
parce que oui je déconne depuis moi
j'aime ça et pour un show puis que ça
soit relativement intégral à ce que
j'entends j'aime ce camp des foyers des
détenus anciens tout le quai mais j'aime
pas ce groupe que je reconnais par ces
sont des signes qui précède avait fixé
ça l'est plus du tout je veux que ça
soit intégrale à ce que j je te rendrai
créé chose c'est important on aura
beaucoup de séquences mais reproche sa
grande arrivée puis que la com des
pêches français quand même un groupe
électro bien des séquences mais on
faisait un siphon djoudi qui bossent dur
mais tu vas aller voir un peu pour ce
sont le existe on le trouve pas arriver
leur puissance
une fender strat blagues et ses méthodes
on a créé des simples qu'on nous paie
qui sont clairement l'étiquette d'une
chanson je suis si te pas tout cette
viande long en dessous mais c'est bien
cool avoir un droit moral il faut qu'un
bon
même si tu as vraiment bon claviériste
il pourrait créer les grands mots va
venir justement une énergie de plus au
live tellement que le doubs des matchs
auront pris avec qui je travaille ouais
mais bien québec se dote d'un matt lui
il ya aussi son pad fakih pouilloux soit
laissant fait qu'il peut faire des deux
factions
ça amène un espèce de truc un peu plus
loin en live ce qu'il faut qu'une coupe
mais oui le à date c'est vraiment juste
de les essayer de changer un peu le
pacing pouvoir qu'est ce qui fonctionne
mieux à tel moment de trouver ma de
trouver ma place en tant que proust
d'amendé why qu'est-ce que je dise j'ai
envie de dire est ce que j'ai envie de
dire des trucs ce que j'ai juste envie
de chanter s'apprête ce jeudi est
carrément donné juste lui aurait pas de
limites acceptées sont infinies ça me
fait ça me fait capoter que tu te te
donne cette permission qu'est ce que ce
cher parce que mettant juste dans son
processus créatif mettons pour faire
l'appareil avec ce que tu viens juste de
dire le dg ce faire j'ai c'est des trucs
pour que ce soit le plus loin possible
puis l'un entre une interprétation à
dire là je présente mes chansons
j'essaie de me trouver moi pour être le
plus proche de moi possible ça me fait
capoter que je fasse je trouve ça
tellement parce que souvent mettons
souvent et du monde yvon qui vont avoir
une idée préconçue dès qu'ils doivent
tahiti c'est quoi l'image qu'ils veulent
projeter sur un style du cde comme
acquis le moi je veux faire subtilement
ça va être sur mon personnage c'est le
personnes âgées scène c'est de dire le
cheveu que tu retrouves en même temps
que the way qu'est ce que j'aime dans le
golfe persique qui semble en être
susciter jeu va le développer en tant
que j'en ai pas fait un million de
choses j'ai pas de développer cette
personne n'en compte exact je trouve ça
vraiment merci mais et mina
vous parlez d'un toit avant d'année m'a
dit attention nina qui mène ce aussi non
c'est pas humain
c'est notre entité et m'a dit tu peux
pas d'excusés de rien quand tu fais ton
or parce que ça pas parce que c'est toi
faut que tu ailles au bout de ce que de
ce que tu as envie d'être sur scène mais
il faut certainement pas que tu
t'excuses d'être là parce que j'ai des
fois c'est un peu un sentiment qui
remonte je fais tout ce que je veux pas
déranger je ss en temps de m'asseoir ce
coin du stade
comptez une anecdote parce que je trouve
seul jeu en deux temps factice un peu
belle feinte s'étaient invités puis
facilité s'il ya des artistes qui ne
s'étaient pas parlé juste parce que
c'est pas leur tasse de thé je dirais
bien sûr fait jamais le monologue sur ce
thème je m c'est peut-être juste parce
que ben ou affiner madrague mais
vraiment prêté six mois ccm étaient ses
projets un genre typiquement 26 et safia
diack a mené à un chouia comme duré
trois heures et demie mais oui parce
qu'un meshaka m'embarquer dans une haie
cela fort plate daniel eck sont taris
pis son parti se creuse de chabran moins
qu'à manger ce tapis quand un car j'ai
habité pictures force pop n'essaie pas
d'être cool tu fais juste et jusqu'où tu
es juste toi tu es là tu lui fais les
gens qui ont payé ton chauffe on ne te
voit rompit ceux qui ont un horaire et
sa grille parce qu'ils sont stressés ils
sont bons puisque harry euros exactement
faut pas s'exciter mettons safiots
justement s'excuse est ce que vous dites
ou dette qui elle et puis justement
quand même qu'à par l'antitrust states
has piquer un genre où je l'aï vu après
la partie sud est mais j'ai vu sa fille
eux dépendent en partie de karim wallet
symphonique genre grands airs ôta québec
type c'est un public justement plus du
grand théâtre depuis plus de symphonies
et le symphonique jeux du québec
tu arrives après la partie avec josette
à risque qui fait le job café puis à
dékon piste depuis alain gautier défense
soit le alpes roman lui demande aussi
que c'était comme moi j'aurais mais
qu'importe pas lieu d'être gérés mais
qu'à part le pauvre qu'elle fait justin
mais c'est quoi ces gens ne sont pas fan
mais c'est pas grave parce qu'il vaut
mieux que ce soit aux fans qu'ils soient
fans d'une personne qui était pas exact
mais là on est en train de faire un
autre force qu avec ce concept à 3,60
c'est ce qui fait tout ce papier c'est
mario en mai par rapport à tes à
l'épisode dont on parlait du jugement bd
je peux pas tu peux pas te nourrir des
qui tend à vide et et espérer aller au
bout de ce que tu es santé non seulement
restreinte par l'ape l'image au pôle
image mais ce que les gens veulent de
toit fixe pour ce que j'essaye de contre
istres c'est ça m'arrive la mousse des
fautes de fuck d'avoir un petit groupe
boule de stress arômes et de cook
il faut juste ajuster sa propre façon de
s'en débarrasser de sepideh des trains
tech deck soit ce qui est beau dans ce
que tu dis aussi tu sais que tu veux
trouver toi tu veux être toi mais ça
vient qu'un travail c'est pô juste être
soi puis être le meilleur soit c'est pas
juste comme rien faire je suis là bas je
fais rien je suis moi même parce que
parce que juju t/t mettons des artistes
que tu dis elle est vraiment elle-même
pièces acquises ces mets ton chez paul
biya halliche le tout du piège à l'homme
est allé travailler son aile c'est
précis que là où elle puisse y croire
personne n'a et d'une intégrale et et
khalid égalité et équité est terminé
pour moi geagea trouve tellement
rafraîchissant dit et je vais oui à
leçon l'ocde fois peu à peu être séparés
et et jill je trouve mobilier les jeux
mais en même temps moi chaque chaque
entrevue que j'ai vu d'elle a l'air
d'être tellement juste l'eau
qui intègre en ça se ressente effet que
c'est sûr que oui aussi l'atsem sa vie
vient de mai dans sa salle c'est quand
même elle pige or sont fracassés débite
dans sa chambre ouais mais cui plus
grosses salles une opinion picom ja
trouverez notre foule bien fait chier
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'elle sort de
caunes nouveau un événement les gueux
jeunes et aspirent à lady se dégager
ouais non placer ce jusqu'en mai non
c'est pas ça si cet exemple pour rien je
trouve que c'est utile vous avez des
parents des parentalité j'avais des
choses un commun j'arrivais shirakawa
est pas le premier à me le dire mais
mais ce compliment mais archi parce que
ça sort tout s'est défaussé de l'enfer
tellement pointu que jusque là j'ai
pensé j'ai développé mon petit des
places à ckoi écoute écoute écoute
écoute m ce que j'écoute en ce moment
mais tout est dans les derniers madame
est en crise qui skie pas ce que veut
pas c'est sûr ça influence la façon que
tu vois le truc
peut-être les mêmes les thématiques je
sais pas qu'est ce que c'est parce que
si côté que tout bouge et jarvis
j'écoute tout en ligne verte afaki ça
mais je reviens tout la même base
c'est comme étant toujours tu reviens
j'ai rappelé un gardien non non mais
hier soir encore dit mettant avant de
coucher fait un noir qui fait tranquille
puisque filer un peu genre mélancolique
j'ai mis ce film stevens le
niasse je reviens tout le temps c'est
revient souvent c'est quoi c'est quoi
j'avais un bon niveau
[Musique]
moissac au secondaire que j'ai un
portable c'est quoi son album avec jean
26 tonnes s'étaient tous des noms su par
le passé dessus elie noah avec chicago
cdb lui seul sait quelque chose
ce gueux le mettons qu'il écoute plus
ces phoques hennebont plus porte
attention parole pis l'étude qui écrit
il raconte une histoire mais pas comme
il raconte pas une histoire de façon
imagée istres et doit raconte une
histoire de la façon la plus narrative
possible c'est quand il raconte ce
trailer être la fois que j'ai appris que
t'avais le cancer puis que ton père tu
as acheté ces lotos d'encours le gentil
c'est un compte gratuit exact dans une
anecdote précises comme ta voix tu vaux
l'histoire d'un simple que ça devienne
utilise des mots comme quitté à midi
j'aurai je me rappelle une tension en
face de l'autre pitt j'avais déjà mon
bac est froid si j'avais mis à quoi
pourquoi sauf qu'il cède immédiatement
belt mettant justement ce que vienne la
world mettant la thune photo la vie
comme si les paroles comme sur l'album
sur la mort de sa mère c'est vraiment
très littérale qui l'hôpital m'a demandé
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec l'accord dit
zafar la mtc genre littérale mais c'est
comme ça plaît il finit à dix ans jean 8
x ou au canada
ces lots il avait la queue lindsey la
beauté d'être ici au québec c'est de la
qualité vous avez beaucoup de parallèles
la balle et google chose la plus si on
dit souvent envie mais bref
l'émeute est originale mais c'est bon
match que climatique mais seuls à 11
heures le soir
cadets chez vous le puits qui mettra en
aucune façon ferme et se regarde par la
fenêtre puis genre tu vas être triste
mais ça va être beau ça va être remplie
de nostalgie ou la nostalgie c'est sain
c'est ramener un moment un mollet
l'odeur c'est souvent le sens qui me
ramène le plus dans une nostalgie des
rôles facture ouais c'est fou je
sentirai parfois jamais c'est ma nounou
un mix c'est chantal oh mon dieu je me
fermais juge dans l'appart pendant deux
saisons c'est fou ce mets ton écouter
mais j'écoutais cher le consul et en
plus je me disais crise qui s'accroche t
il sans quelque chose peut s'y colle au
lui servit https le parfum je n'avais
jamais réalisé à quel point cet effort
jusqu'à teint qui a amené chanteur
parfum qui me ramène un moment précis
puis je savais par coeur que c'était le
jasick au port que tu es la fin jean je
le savais je me mens de sherlock holmes
et comme jessie copa que philippe déjà
exactement c'est parfois généralement le
sens le plus associé la même ordre
ouais mais meiway est un faux nom
m'estimer ton huawei
bah moi je pense que maxime est on
à disposition de chacun étant c'est
comme dalles dans l'essence le qu'existe
le goût touché wall hover le sens qui
voit qu'il est plus fort avec les mêmes
mots fléchés ça veut pas ça c'est l'été
l'aude le louis ouais ça ça l'est aussi
mais mais mais chapeau que cette façon
c'est l'aîné a parfois des daleks monex
sans son par astel note ce cas oui j'ai
lu longtemps si les parfums message est
[Musique]
battable make me mon beau père j'haïs a
acheté le faut qu'une notice qu'à un
moment donné avec maintenant une fois de
temps en temps quand je vois et les voir
et à bromont il va sentir jusqu'à choisi
n'importe quelle autre année à charbon
les genres gilles papillon pleine bourre
beauté au décès commencer par sambre xl
est approprié le party-game puis ça
sentait dans notre champ parce que je
prend sa chance sa santé sur tout le
temps puis à chaque fois que je vois
cendres et qu'il continue à l'utiliser
promettons on se donne une robe
quinconces voix puis fait thalys en
ramène dans l'automate statistiques
c'est comme agissait dans un break sur
allah comme ça fait cette personne
d'autre que j'ai fait aux dés avec le
même à davos on se voit souvent mais ça
fait pas ce sens drake s'est à chaque
fois comme que je le sens ça me ramène
le complément de charme à bali le genre
si tu es là chaque fois fait qu'est ce
que c'est que ce qu'on me demande ce que
j'écoute j'en ai aucune des maths ans il
était encore les playlists 25 plus
écoutée sourate j'aimerais l'être encore
je pense que oui je sais ça c'est le 25
juin
comment jack ma première attaque c'est
jean-louis la cruauté better things
méditer charbon c'est lutter
sarah devant s'agit un peu ce genre de
gambe en hiver boni veut bonhivers
alabama chèque c'est bon ça alors ouais
ouais bonne image mais le bac comme
indochine pacte je fais que leonard
cohen
quant à susan site les bee gees aussi
juste après justement les budgets
soudaine ces grecs ou les albums que
j'ai la dalle riffaud kingsey falls
actuellement bon un ig et vraiment je
trouve qu'elle allait elle aussi h1n1
sans plus et vic table c'est plus simple
andré que plus accès à la personne elle
aussi ce n'est un peu comme sofiane
stevens qui va dire les affaires com et
son site
non c'est vrai avoue utiliser les livres
et molettes seppi c'est un enfant que je
trouve aussi mathon avec jean leloup le
sait qu il dit hawkesbury le ticket lui
qui allait refaire sa vie à hawkesbury
qui est idiot hawkesbury parce que c'est
faux king spirit
ouais parce que c'est l'autre il répète
puis c'est sur c'est là c'est ce qu'à
mieux pas il sait pas une vérité qui
rime l'epo besoin d'une réelle il ya
besoin du nom de la ville mais c'est
vrai qu'on se souvient de ses chansons
le roi qui s'alarme m paul de magie mais
la nature y est bonne à darrouy des mots
comme ajustements pepsico le sida le
plein des gens des poteaux qui monte
mais je trouve dans ses albums l'état et
chercher aussi des mélodies vraiment
rock tallano toujours hull
je trouverais manqué dans chacune des
chansons s'est rasé c'est la thèse c'est
très varié ça se répète pas mais s'il
faut l'assumer
ce très chaud vraiment bien par an j'ai
orchestré sa pas de bon sens
on se permet des tonnes de neuf minutes
aussi aussi mais rendu le plus bel faska
veut enfin y ai fait deux ans qu'on voit
c'est vrai on est déjà en dia 2 à passer
devant brandon compagnie c'était
vraiment un plaisir discute avec toi
merci beaucoup
higuain grand plaisir merci ça c'est sûr
des moines tibétains attente attente
au-dessus de nous et on finit tous les
podcasts avec 3 me le tran
-
maintenant les gars
j'ai déjà détendue merci tout ce monde
avoir été licencié vous écoutez le sens
face aux ondes
ça fait pas cas ce arrête
[Musique]